لما تسوّق للفحص الطبي، ما قبل الزواج
أن هو اللي سوف يعطيك الزواج الصحي
واحنا على منصة الآن، أقول أنها غير دقيقة
خارج المنصة ممكن أقول أنها كذب
افترض أن عندك أداة سحرية تخليك تضغط على زر واحد وزر اثنين
زر واحد، ينتج طفل عنده مشكلة
وزر اثنين، طفل ما عنده المشكلة اللي يعاني منها الطفل الأول
إذا تجرأت بالسماح بزر حق أن هذا ما يجيك
راح تجيك أزرار كثير في المستقبل
أنا  والله ما أبغى واحد عنده مثلًا سمنة
وبالتالي احنا راح ننقرض في العالم مباشرة
أنا ما أبغى أحد يكون مثلًا أصلع
وبالتالي ضعف انقراض بالنسبة لي
أهلًا، هذا فنجان من ثمانية
وأنا عبدالرحمن أبو مالح
شفت أفلام وسمعت وقرأت كثير عن موضوع تصميم البشر
ما أدري ليه هذا الاهتمام، لكن الأكيد أن دافعه فضول
2012 ظهرت تقنية قد تغيّر شكل البشرية كليًّا
طبعًا قد أقولها وأنا ما أودي أقولها
لأني أتوقع أن فعليًّا ستتغير البشرية تمامًا
وأحيانًا أقول، الحمد لله، أني بموت قبل تصير هذه الخرابيط كلها
لأن المستقبل فعلًا ماني قادر أتصوره
التقنية اسمها «كريسبر»
فكرتها هو القدرة على قراءة وتعديل الجينات
الوعد حقها، أنك تقدر تغيير الجينات قبل يولد الإنسان من قبل التلقيح
أو تقدر إذا تبغى تغيّرها بعد ما يولد
تقدر تغيّر لون شعره، لون بشرته
مو بس كذا، تبغى تغيّر طوله؟ غيّر
قوة عضلاته، حتى ذكاءه، أي شيء
يسمون هذه الفكرة تصميم الأطفال
هل هي متاحة اليوم؟ لا
لكن هل بتصير بعد سنوات قليلة؟ وارد
هل مسموحة؟ يعني
هل هي أخلاقية؟
الجلسة هذه جلسة وحديث مثري للغاية، ممتع ورائع
لعلها من أفضل ما سمعته في نقاش هذه الفكرة
مع ضيفي الدكتور «عبدالله عدلان»
مستشار في الأخلاقيات الحيوية
ورئيس الأخلاقيات بالمعهد الوطني لأبحاث الصحة
قبل أن نبدأ، وبالحديث عن الجينات وتأثيرها على حياتنا
نشرنا قبل سنة سلسلة من ست وثائقيات قصيرة
تأخذك في رحلة مع أصغر مكوّن فيك، اللي هو «الجين»
بس يشرح لك بشكل علمي مبسط
تأثير الجينات على شخصيتك وصفاتك وأمراضك وحتى مستقبلك
تركت لك رابط السلسلة في وصف هذه الحلقة
إذا أعجبتك الحلقة هذه؛ تعجبك هذه السلسلة بالضرورة
شكرًا لراعي هذه الحلقة شركة «صفا» ومنصة «سلة»
أما الآن لنبدأ
كيف شفت «جينو» السلسلة؟
والله جميلة
والله؟
جميلة
كما توقعتها؟
ما كانت محايدة
ليش؟
بس كما توقعتها
ليه ما هي محايدة؟
كانت الرواية اللي حاولت تسوّق لها
أن ترى كويس أنك تفحص
أها، بس الرواية سليمة هذه وللا؟
الحلو أنك تعطي البشرية، مثلًا
ناس تولد بأمراض مزمنة أو بعاهات أو بمشاكل طبية
وفقًا لجينات وراثية تناقلوها ما بينهم، كان يمدي تفاديها
تفاديها فقط بأن لا تزوجونهم، أنتم الاثنين ما تنفعون
تزوجوا من غير بعض، لكن أنتم الاثنين لا تتزوجون
نسأل سؤال أكبر، يلقي الضوء شوي على الإجابة على السؤال هذا
هل نستطيع التخلص من جميع الأمراض المزمنة؟
أو الأمراض المكلفة، الأمراض البشعة؟
يمكن ليش لا، إذا نقدر؛ ليش لا
الإجابة لا، ما نقدر
الموضوع مو مثل الكوليرا
الكوليرا استطاع البشر أنهم يتعاملوا معها بصورة إيجابية
هنا الموضوع يختلف تمامًا
كل شخص فينا يحمل ما لا يقل عن خمسة إلى عشرة طفرات جينية
كل شخص، هذا وأنا متحفّظ جدًّا
فيه ناس يقول لك خمسين، فيه ناس يقول لك سبعين وأكثر
كم من الطفرات هذه تؤثر على حياتي؟
بعضنا يطلع متين، بعضنا يطلع صحي
بعضنا يطلع أبيض، بعضنا يطلع أسود
بعضنا يطلع أعمى، بعضنا يطلع بصره قوي، بعضنا يطلع أصلع
اختلافات جينية هي اللي بتحدد الماهية الشكلية للشخص
والماهية الكيميائية أيضًا، البيولوجية للجسم
الآن، إذا قلنا نستطيع جعل الإنسان وحدة خالية من الأمراض
هذا أنت بتخالف مبادئ الإحصاء، مبادئ العلم، مبادئ الواقع
لا تستطيع مهما فعلت أن تُخرج سلالة بشرية خالية من الأمراض
وإذا استطعت، شوف أنا بنروح معاك للتطرف الآن
إذا استطعت أنك تنشئ إنسان خالي من الأمراض
سلالة البشرية خالية من الأمراض
لن تستطيع أن تُخرج إنسان أو سلالة بشرية خالية من المعاناة
المعاناة بمعناها الأشمل من المرض
والمعاناة راح تدخل أيضًا في موضوع الأساس
المعاناة هذه هل هي موضوع نفسي وللا موضوع غير نفسي
وندخل عاد في موضوع، هل هذا له علاقة بالاكتئاب
وهل الاكتئاب يورث وما يورث، والأمور هذه
أنا أرى الإجابة على أن نخرج بسلالة بشرية خارجة
كما قال الطبيب مثل ما يقولوا
سلالة بشرية كما أرادتها الآلة الطبية غير منطقي
وغير ممكن وغير معقول
وغير أخلاقي؟
هذا موضوع ثاني، نحن نتكلم عن فلسفيًّا الآن
اللي ممكن نُسقط عليه حكم أخلاقي هو الأداة اللي يتم استخدامها
ليس الفكرة، الفكرة سامية
الفكرة ما فيها أي مشكلة
الفكرة في حد ذاتها ما في مشكلة
نأتي للأداة التي سوف يتم استخدامها
ما فيها مشكلة أخلاقية؟
بالعكس إذا استطعت أن تُنشئ ذلك؛ الله يقويك، روح
أنت أساسًا على المستوى الشرعي، أنت مطالب بإعمار الأرض
وجزء من إعمار الأرض، أنت مطالب بأن تعتني بنفسك وبصحتك
وتسوي ما يجب أنك تسويه، ولا تهلك نفسك
ولا تقوم بالأمور التي تؤدي للمهلكة إلى آخره
فالفكرة نفسها ما عندي مشكلة على الفكرة
الأدوات اللي ممكن تقودنا للفكرة
قد تؤدي إلى عسكرة المجتمع لصالح الآلة الطبية
الآن الفحص الطبي، كم مرض يجبر الزوجان على أن يفحصان عنها؟
الفحص الطبي الملزم للزواج وللا؟
الملزم
الظاهر أربعة أمراض، صح؟
نعم، مرضين جينيين ومرضين اللي هي من الأمراض الجنسية المعدية
لما تسوق للفحص الطبي، ما قبل الزواج
أن هو اللي سوف يعطيك الزواج الصحي
هذه أنا من وجهة نظري، واحنا على منصة الآن أقول أنها غير دقيقة
خارج المنصة ممكن أقول أنها كذب
فهي بكل بساطة غير دقيقة بكل الأدب الاجتماعي
اللي الممكن يقال في مثل هذه الادّعاءات
ليه؟
احنا بنسجّل؟
إيه
من بدري؟ الله يستر مدري أيش قلت
لا، كل شيء تمام
عشان نحدد إذا ممكن وللا لا الادّعاء هذا
نحاكم تفاصيله
لما نقول صحي، أيش نقصد بصحي؟
أتوقع أنهم يقصدون إذا كنت
خالي من المرضين
لا، بالنسبة للأمراض المعدية واضح
ما عندك أي نقاش عليها؟
لا، ما عندي نقاش عليها الآن
أنت عندك على الوراثية
نعم
أول شيء، هم أيش يعالجون؟
الأنيميا المنجلية، ومرض آخر يتعلق بأمراض الدم
فإذا أنا بقي الأطفال من هذه المرضين
لأن كان واضح أن المرضين منتشرين عند الناس
وخصوصًا في مجتمع، أنا بتوقع، ما أعرف أيش جالسين يسوون
الحين أنا جالس أكيّس إذا تسمح لي
إيه تفضّل
الكيس عندي واسع
والله كلهم يكيّسون، بس كمّل. كلنا ذاك الرجل
أقول يمكن لأنهم درسوا الجينوم السعودي
أو المشاكل الموجودة في السعودية أو في الخليج
ووجدوا أن هذين المرضين ينتشرون بحكم تقارب الناس وزواج الأقارب
فلذا عشان نقضي عليهم، يجب أن نتأكد
أن ماهي موجودة عند أحد الطرفين
يعني ما راح يورثونها لأولادهم
بالضبط
فنسوي هذا الفحص الطبي
إيه نعم، وهذا كلام جميل
وهذا على أساسه تم اختيار المرضين هذه
وتم إجبار الناس عليها
نجي للأداة عشان نصل للهدف هذا
الأداة عبارة عن تدخل في الحياة الاجتماعية
الآن أنت كأنك بتقول أن أنا عندي أكثر من قيمة
لكن بحاول أطلّع القيم من الجملتين أو الثلاثة التي تفضلت فيها حضرتك
قيمة اقتصادية، وإن كنت ما ذكرتها بصورة مباشرة
بس أن المرضين هذول مكلفين جدًّا على ميزانية الدولة
قيمة اجتماعية، أو بالأصح قيمة شخصية
اللي هو بتعريف أن الشخص هذا على سبيل المثال
ناخذ مرض الأنيميا المنجلية هو الأبشع
مثلًا يحتاج الشخص أن كل أسبوعين
يجي له أزمة يدخل المستشفى ويصير مدمن على أدوية محددة
وبالتالي، هذه القيمة الصحية الشخصية لها تبعاتها المؤلمة
أيضًا هناك قيمة على مستوى الاجتماع
اللي هو قيمة الزواج نفسه
أن هذولي الاثنين مفترض أنهم ما يتزوجوا
لأنهم لو تزوجوا بينتجوا هذا الشخص
اللي راح يُعذب، اللي راح يكلف الآلة الطبية كذا وكذا، تتابعية
فجاء الفحص الطبي قال نجي من تحت
رقم واحد، اللي نستطيع أن نتدخل فيه
أنتم يا الاثنين، أول حاجة راح نقول لكم لا تتزوجون
ما راح نوقف عند هنا
راح نقول لكم إذا تزوجتوا؛ الزواج هذا زواج غريب
احنا نقول لكم لا تتزوجوا، وأنتوا تتزوجوا
فأنتم اتخذتوا قرار غريب
بعد شوية، أنتم اتخذتوا قرار غير مقبول
بعد شوية، أنتم اتخذتوا قرار غير أخلاقي
بعد شوية، أنتم قررتم أنكم تخرجوا عن الطبيعي حق المجتمع
وبالتالي أنتم لا تستحقون العناية الصحية
أنتم لا تستحقون احترام الآلة الطبية
وهذه الخطوات واقعية
أنا ما أتكلم عن شيء نظري، لا هذا واقع
هذا اللي قاعد يحصل الآن
بس اللي جالس يحصل الآن
أنهم يقولون أنتم ما تنفعون، بس بكيفكم
هذا حاليًّا على مستوى أن نقول لك...
تجلسون جلسة معهم؟
إيه
استشارية؟ أن إذا تزوجتوا بيجي هذا المرض في أطفالكم
نعم
فأنتم غير مطابقين، الأفضل أنكم ما تتزوجون
بس تبغوا تتزوجون؛ قراركم
هذه بصورة جميلة جدًّا لما يجب أن يكون
ما أعرف أنا أيش يصير
لكن الواقع أن اللحظة اللي يُعطى فيها الخبر
يصير فيه عملية إعطاء الإشارة الأخلاقية
أنتم ما عندكم ضوء أخضر أخلاقي أن تتزوجوا
تبغوا تتزوجوا؛ بكيفكم
مثل لما تقول الحجر من الأرض والدم من رأسك
أنت على الخيار
صحيح
تبغى تكسر رأسك؟ أنت حر، أنا أشوفها أنها...
أنت أخذت أنها رأسمالية وأنها تهلك الآلة الطبية
ما وصلت، بس تفضّل
بس ممكن ناخذها وبخليها تحت؟
فعلًا لأن يولد ناس أصحاء؛ خلونا نشتغل على هذا الموضوع
فإذا التقنية الطبية وصلت لنا أننا نقدر
نحمي أطفالنا وأجيالنا من مرض
فنعمّا هو، ليش تشوفه غير أخلاقي؟
بالعكس ممتاز، ترى إذا أنت سويته ولدك بيصير مثل كذا
هل تبغى أولادك يعانون؟
مو عشان تهلك الآلة، أنا بدفع لك ما عندي مشكلة
أنا ملزم بعلاجك، لن أتردد في ذلك
بس هل أنت تبغى تعاني؟ هل أنت راضي أن ولدك يعاني؟
هذا كلام منطقي وجميل
الشخص المحايد لا يجد فيه مثلبًا
إلى أن تدخل في التفاصيل
في التفاصيل؟
أي نعم. أول شيء راح أسألك، لما تقول أن ولدك ما راح يعاني
هل إذا سمعت كلامك الآلة طبية
هل ولدي ما راح يعاني؟ الإجابة لا قطعًا
ما لم تكن إلهًا؛ لن تستطيع أن تمنع المعاناة في الأرض
وهذه سنة كونية
وبالتالي أنت تركز على ما يهمك من المعادلة
اللي يهمك أن الولد هذا راح يكلفك
وللا فيه أشياء أخطر وأبشع من الأنيميا المنجلية
مثل؟
مرض «هنتنقتون» مثلًا
ليش نروح بعيد، ليش نروح للبشع
نروح للبسيط؛ السرطان. ماهو بسيط طبعًا
بس السرطان يورّث؟
طبعًا، أثبتوا أن هناك جينات هي المسؤولة عن وجود أشخاص
لهم قابلية أن يصابون بمرض السرطان
مثلًا سرطان الثدي، سرطان البروستاتا، سرطان القولون
كلها في مورثات محددة هي اللي وجودها
يؤدي إلى نسبة أكبر من حدوث المرض
وبالتالي إذا نبغى نفكر في الإنسان المؤتمت طبيًّا
خلينا ننتج هذا الإنسان الخارق
ولكن نجي لفكرة أننا لن نستطيع
وبالتالي نحن بنختار من الرواية الشيء اللي يناسبنا
ثم نضع فيه أحكام، أن إذا تزوجتوا أنتم ...
فيه بعض الدول من اللي حولنا
وصلت إلى أن، تبغوا تتزوجوا؟ تمام
أول شيء المنع، ثم لما وجدوا فيه مقاومة من المجتمع
قالوا تمام، بس ترى ما لنا علاقة بعلاج أطفالكم
طيب هذا الطفل اللي قاعد يتألم
أيش دخله في الغلطة التاريخية اللي ارتكبها والديه؟
إذا أتفقنا أن هذه كانت غلطة تاريخية
نجي لموضوع اللي بدينا فيه من البداية
اللي هو تغوّل الآلة الطبية على القيم الاجتماعية
أنت ذكرت مثلًا زواج الأقارب بصورة عرضية
أنها قد تكون السبب في نسبة الأمراض الوراثية المرتفعة
زواج الأقارب، قيمة اجتماعية مهمة عندنا
فيه بعض الأسر أو القبائل معتمد التوافق الاجتماعي
على عملية الزواج نفسها
أنت بتاخذ مين؟ من فين؟ أنت بتعطي بنتك لمين؟
هذه لها حسابات اجتماعية
نحن لا نقول صح أو خطأ هنا
لكن نقول أنها قيم اجتماعية واقعية يجب النظر إليها كقيم
وأن لا يُسمح بالتداخل فيها
أحيانًا قيم الستر
فيه قصة مو مشهورة، قصة وقفت على بعض أبجدياتها
كوني أعتبر مستشار في موضوع الأخلاقيات
وكان فيه مؤتمر في إحدى الدول، نناقش في هذا الموضوع بالتحديد
وبسبب رأيي؛ أثار كثير من اللغط
كيف أنت تقول الكلام هذا؟
من أي منطلق أنت بتقول أن الفحص هذا فيه مشكلة؟
وهذه فيها تفصيل، أنا ما بقول أن الفحص هذا فيه مشكلة
أنا بقول أن الفحص هذا ممكن يكون أحسن
عملية الرواية اللي يسوّق فيها؛ فيها مشكلة، الرواية التسويقية
نرجع للي صار، للإشكالية
سيدة محترمة من أصل محترم، من مكان محترم، من عائلة جيدة
ورجل أيضًا يشارك من أصل محترم، من عائلة جيدة
وصغيرين في السن، عشرينات
والشيطان شاطر، حصل بينهم ما كان لا يجب أن يكون
وأدّى إلى أن يصير فيه حمل من علاقة غير شرعية
الآن، الأب عرف، وصار فيه نوع من أنواع حرب إلا شوي
فدخلوا العقلاء، وقالوا مستعدين أن الموضوع يتلملم
ويُستر على جميع الأطراف بعملية الزواج
ويُدفع المهر اللي أنتوا تبغوه والرضوة اللي تبغوها
وأبد، وإن شاء الله، ما يصير إلا كل خير
وافقوا، اتفقوا على ذلك
على عِظم الجريمة، على عِظم ما كان
على الصعوبات الجمّة اللي حصلت في التوافق
وحرب إلا شوي، ودم إلا شوي
شاف الطبيب، قال والله أنتوا الاثنين ما تنفعوا لبعض
ليش؟ لأن احتمال من سيكون، راح يكون فيه مشكلة الأنيميا المنجلية
أو أنيميا الفول «G6PD»
اللحظة هذه هي اللحظة التي ترعب الأخلاقي
هي اللحظة التي يقول فيها الطبيب كلمته على الثابت الاجتماعي
عملية التسويق للفحوصات هذه هي المشكلة وليست الفحوصات
الفحوصات مهمة
على أساس ما يؤخذ عني فكرة أن الفحوصات هذه سيئة
الفحوصات مهمة ونحتاجها
وقد أرجع أعارض حتى نفسي عندما أقول
أنها قد تؤدي إلى حياة أفضل في المستقبل
لكن الوعود البراقة هذه هي المشكلة
أيش الوعود البراقة؟
الوعود البراقة أن الزواج غير صحي مثلًا
هو ليس زواج صحي عشان أخذت الفحص هذا
الفحص هذا يخدمني في حاجتين محددتين
أن الشخص هذا ما راح خبّص وجاب لي مشكلة لبنتي
والشيء الثاني، أن الشخص هذا وبنتي ما عندهم الأنيميا المنجلية
وبالتالي المستقبل للأطفال، بإذن الله، على قدرتي ما راح يكون فيه
هذا بكل بساطة اللي بيقوله الفحص هذا
ماهو زواج صحي، ماهو الكلام الكبير اللي قاعد...
ولا يقلل من زواج الأقارب وإلى آخره من الكلام هذا
نجي للسؤال مهم، وهذا سؤال فلسفي
هل يحق لي كشخص موجود الآن
أني أحدد من يأتي ومن لا يأتي، بناءً على المستوى الصحي؟
بمعنى افترض أن عندك أداة سحرية
تخليك تضغط على زر واحد وزر اثنين
زر واحد، ينتج طفل عنده مشكلة
وزر اثنين، طفل ما عنده المشكلة اللي يعاني منها الطفل الأول
حتى نكون مرة دقيقين
ما هو الواجب الأخلاقي لحوكمة ضغطة الزر هذه؟
لأن ضغطة الزر هذه معناته أنت بتحرم من سيكون على الوجود
كأنك تقول أنت لا تناسبنا كمجتمع، وبالتالي نحن لا نريدك
وهذه وإن كان فكرة فلسفية، لكن لها تبعاتها على الواقع
قد تقود تفكيرنا إلى طريقة مختلفة في النظر للفحوصات هذه
اللي تعتبر نوع من أنواع تحسين النسل، مثل ما يسموها في التخصص
اللي هو الانتخاب الجيني الطبي
إذا تجرأت بالسماح بالزر حق أن هذا ما يجيه
راح تجيك أزرار كثير في المستقبل
مثل؟
أنا ما أبغى واحد عنده مثلًا سمنة
وبالتالي نحن راح ننقرض في العالم مباشرة
أنا ما أبغى أحد يكون مثلًا أصلع، وبالتالي ضعف انقراض بالنسبة لي
أنا ما أبغى أحد يكون مثلًا عنده...
نقص نظر، ثلاثة
ثلاثة، وهكذا
إذا شرعنت ضغطة الزر هذه
راح تجد نفسك دخلت في ما يسمونه أخلاقيًّا المنزلق اللزج
أنه لن تستطيع أن تقف
دائمًا راح يجيك شخص برواية أو بقصة تجعلك مقتنع أن تتبنّاها
دائمًا سوف يأتيك هذا الشخص
متى ما تبنيتها؛ أنت انزلقت شوية تحت، كمان شوية، إلى آخره
أنا ما كان ودي أتكلم في الفحص ما قبل الزواج
ولا كان ودي، لكنه حديث راح
طيب خلنا ندخل وننزلق شوي
احنا بندخل على موضوعنا
أنت بتحدد أن الآن عندي خيارين أن أضغط الزر
أما أنه يجي وللا ما يجي على الوجود وللا لا
فإذا افترضنا أننا نقدر نعرف أنه بيكون أصلع
فاحنا ما نبغى صلعان. أيمن بيختفي
بروح أنا وأنت العالم موازي
بس إلا نقدر نقول، احنا ما نبغاه
خل نغيّر في الجينات حقته ويصير شعره تمام
فأنا فعلًا خليتك تجي، بس أني غيّرت فيك
شفت مشاكلك ذي؟ شلتَها
جيت واحد «إكّة» أيش المشكلة في الموضوع هذا؟
عرّف الـ «إكّة» وما هي مقاييس الـ «إكّة» هذه؟
مقاييسي أنا
هذا مخرج حلو
أكيد أن فيه أحد، بس لما نقول التعديل الجيني، وهو موضوعنا اليوم
ودي أعرف أيش الممكن وأيش الخيال
هل أقدر أغيّر طفل أخليه يكون نظره قوي مو أصلع، غير سمين، جينيًّا؟
لا
لا؟
أيش اللي تقدر تسويه؟
أنت تتكلم عن الممكن؟
إيه
الممكن لا
هل أقدر أغير لونه؟
لا
صعّبت عليّ، لون عيونه؟
طوله؟
لا
ذكاءه؟
أيش أقدر أغيّر؟
هذا هو السؤال الصح
ما هي تقنية التغيير الجيني «الكريسبر» أو الأداة اللي مستخدمة
وما هي إمكانياتها، وما هي وعودها؟
بكل بساطة هي أداة كتابة على الجين
الحين نظريًّا كل الأسئلة اللي أنت قلتها
الإجابة نعم نظريًّا
مخبريًّا على المستوى مثلًا البكتيري وعلى المستوى الحيواني البسيط
ما نتكلم عن الرئيسيات، نتكلم عن اللي يسموها الحيوانات المتقدمة
القردة أو الشامباينيز والبابونز
لا، نتكلم عن حيوانات أقل تطورًا
يقال، حسب الفحوصات، وحسب الأبحاث
أن فيه من استطاع أن ينتج فأر مثلًا عنده إمكانيات رياضية عالية
فيه من زعم أنه قدر يحارب الشيخوخة
حسب تعريف محدد من تعاريفها
فيه بعض حيونات التجارب معظم العمل على الفئران
فنعم من ناحية نظرية، تستطيع أنك تفعل الكثير بالتقنية هذه
من ناحية عملية، على الإنسان يمكن قبل أشهر قريبة...
الآن أيش اللي تسويه «كريسبر»
لو نبغى نتكلم عن «كريسبر»
علميًّا
الآن الحمض النووي قروه من قبل، أتوقع بداية الألفية السابقة، صح؟
نعم
عندهم قراءة كاملة للحمض النووي للإنسان
نعم، لكن...
و«كريسبر» كم؟ 2012؟
نعم
أيش تسوي؟
«كريسبر» بصورة بسيطة هي بتقرأ الجين
هي عبارة عن مثل الكتابة على الخطأ
الآن كيف بتحصل الأمراض الوراثية؟
تحصل الأمراض الوراثية عن طريق أن الجسم يتكون بروتينات
والبروتينات هذه هي اللي تحدد عمل الجسم
هي اللي تسيطر على الجسم، الهرمونات عبارة عن بروتينات
فكل الجسم عبارة عن سيطرة هرمونية بروتينية بحتة
نجي لمن فين جات البروتينات هذه؟
هذه جات من الشفرة الجينية اللي في الإنسان
هذا مثلًا تلقاه عنده سمنة، لأن عنده هرمون أو عنده إنزيم ما بيشتغل
ما بيشتغل لأنه معطوب من الأساس في الجين
أيش يعني معطوب؟ يعني تسلسل القواعد النيتروجينية
أنا ما ابغى أدخل في الجوانب الفنية كثير
تسلسل القواعد النيتروجينية اللي ينتج البروتين السليم
فيه خلل، فيه طفرة جينية، فيه اختلاف فيه
ليس هو ما يجب أن يكون
فبينتج شخص عنده ضعف في إنتاج هذا الإنزيم
أو هذا البروتين، أو هذا الهرمون، أيًّ كان المادة اللي بينتجها
وبالتالي أدّى إلى أن العملية الحرق مثلًا في جسمه
ماهي مثل الحرق في جسم الرياضي المتماثل
وبالتالي تراكم الدهون عنده إلى آخره، يختلف
فهذا كيف بيصير المرض مثل ما تقول باختصار مخل جدًّا جدًّا
أيش بتسوي «كريسبر»؟ «كريسبر» بتقرأ
أنا عشان أوصل لمرحلة «كريسبر»
لازم أول حاجة أعرف أيش هو الطبيعي بالنسبة للجين
هذا بالتحديد الجين اللي أنا بتكلم عنه
أيش هو الغير طبيعي، الطفرة بالضبط أكون عارفها أيش هي
وبعد كذا آخذ الطفرة هذه أعرّف عليها «كريسبر»
أقول لـ«كريسبر» لما تقرأ، إذا وصلت للطفرة هذه
الطفرة هذه عبارة عن تسلسل محدد
من أربعة قواعد نيتروجينية باختلافها
طبعًا ممكن يكون عشرين، ممكن يكون ألف
أو أيًّ كان من التسلسلات هذه
بس هم عبارة عن أربعة قواعد جينية تتكرر بصورة مختلفة
متى ما وصلت إلى هذه القراءة، اللي بالنسبة لي قراءة معتلة
واللي راح تعطيني مشكلة
تعال قص هذه القراءة، وحط مكانها القراءة السليمة
كذا تبرمج مجموعة الإنزيمات اللي بتشتغل على «الكريسبر»
هذا بداية «الكريسبر»
نجح في الزراعة إلى حدٍ ما، نجح في بعض التخصصات
ثم قالوا ليش ما نستغل هذه الفكرة في الطب؟
جميل، كيف ناويين تستغلون هذه الفكرة في الطب؟
نبغى ننتج علاجات. ممتاز، انتجوا علاجات، الله يوفقكم
طالما أن العلاجات هذه ما راح توصل للسوق
إلا بعد ما تأخذ حقها من الدراسة؛ ما عندنا مشكلة
ثم جاء العالم العفريت اللي قال لك
لحظة، أنا أقدر أغيّر نظريًّا في مستقبل البشرية
أقدر ألعب في خلايا المنشأ
أقدر ألعب في الإنسان قبل أن يصبح إنسانًا
عندما كان حُيين وبويضة
أقدر ألعب على مستوى الحُيين وعلى مستوى البويضة
واُخرج الإنسان الخارق «إكّة»
هذا هو ليس شخصية هو فكرة طبعًا
هذه الفكرة بدأ كثير يتناولها بحرص في البداية
ثم قبل حوالي خمسة سنوات جاءت الطامة الكبرى
أن أحد الأشخاص في الصين
قال لقد استخدمت «كريسبر» وأنتجت توأم
بتغيير خريطتهم الجينية قبل الولادة
وجعل هاذين الطفلين عندهم مناعة من مرض الإيدز
طبعًا أصبح العالم الطبي كله متوتر من هذه المعلومة
تعال هنا، أنت أيش سويت بالضبط؟
كيف وصلت لمرحلة أنك تستخدم «كريسبر» على الجينات البشرية
أيش بالضبط اللي أنت سويته؟
وكيف تقدر تعرف أن اللي أنت سويته هذا
ما له تبعات خطيرة، ماهو تبعات عادية
ففي البداية، صعب أني أحط إحصائية
بس بعض العلماء قالوا وصلنا، واستطعنا
بس بعد ذلك، الغالبية العظمى قالوا لا، هناك شيء خاطئ هنا
هنا، نحن دخلنا في موضوع أخطر من علاج الإيدز
أولًا ما نعرف أيش اللي حصل
وما نقدر نحكم على جدية التجربة ولا مصداقيتها ولا تبعاتها
وبالتالي، اللي فعله هذا الرجل تعتبر جريمة أخلاقية بكل المقاييس
طبعًا اللي صار، كان فيه مؤتمر بعدها بكم يوم
ووقف الرجل، طُلب منه أن يتكلم عن الإنجاز هذا
فكان واضح، اللي يعرف لغة الجسد، صورة مشهورة
كان واقف يدينه وراء ظهره، ورافع كتوفه ومنزّل رأسه
كأنه شخص مسوي جريمة
وهي لغة الجسد بتقول لك أيش المشكلة
أنه خرق خرقًا ما كان ينبغي له أن يخرقه
حتى الحكومة الصينية تبرأت من الفعل هذا
وصدر قرار بسجن الشخص هذا
بسبب أنه تلاعب في جينات بشرية
بدون ما يكون له أي نوع من أنواع المصداقية
أو بدون ما يقول للناس أيش سوّى
وكيف سوى وأيش النتيجة وأيش المحاذير
وأيش الأدوات اللي بيستخدمها وأيش الأدوات اللي ما راح يستخدمها
ومتى يقف ومتى يُقدم وإلى آخره
أسئلة كثيرة يجب أن يجاوب عليها الباحث قبل أن يدخل في المجال هذا
فهذه فكرة أنه ...
هو شخص عادي وللا باحث معتبر؟
هو باحث، بس معتبر ما أظنه من مشاهير الباحثين
ما يعتبر من الثقات في المجال هذا
وهذه خطورة الأدوات البحثية
مش شرط تكون أستاذ كبير عشان تقترف الجريمة هذه
الأداة وسهولتها؛ يخلينا نقف كثير على إتاحتها للناس
بدون ما تكون فيه دقة واضحة
هل نحن نريد أن نخلق جينات في القبو مثل ما يقولون
هل مسموح لنا أن نستخدم التقنية عشان ننتج جيل ذو صفات محددة؟
كل هذه الأسئلة اجمعها، وراح تلقاها عبارة عن كرة ثلج
كلما تدحرجت؛ كلما تكبر
ولن تجد لمعظمها إجابات
وبالتالي القفز إلى ليش ما نستخدمها عن كذا كذا؟
أنا أقول لك قبل حوالي شهر أو شهرين
تم الإعلان عن دواء بعلاج جيني محدد
يعالج الظاهر مرض أو مرضين، والله ما أذكر
قد يكون الأنيميا المنجلية من ضمنهم
عن طريق استخدام تقنية
فوصلوا إلى استخدام التقنية هذه بصورة جيدة للعلاج
كم تكلفت العلاج هذا؟
تقريبًا 3 مليون دولار للشخص الواحد
للشخص واحد؟
نعم
فهذا يقودك إلى العبثية الاقتصادي في الموضوع
لكن نقول أملًا أن في البداية قد يكون هذا السعر
لكن في المستقبل قد يختلف
الحين التعديل الجيني بـ «كريسبر»
أيش شكله؟ هل هو دواء ممكن تاخذه؟
هو إبرة تاخذها؟ أو عملية جراحية؟
شلون يتم التعديل الجيني؟
إبرة
إبرة، ومفترض يتغير الجين
طريقة التناول، إبرة هي الأقرب للذهن
الإجراء نفسه ماهو إجراء خذ إبرة وامشي
لا، فيه طبعًا تجهيز وفيه احتياطات، وفيه ما قبل وما بعد
فيه عملية تجهيز للحظة المناسبة اللي يتم فيها أخذ العلاج هذا
وفيه طبعًا عملية المتابعة بعدها
فالموضوع ليس فقط حبة تنبلع أو إبرة تنضرب
لا، هي عبارة عن ريجيم كامل
بس أن العمل؛ إبرة
الحين خل ناخذ الفكرة من «كريسبر» وقدرة التعديل الجيني
وفقًا للمتاح والمعلوم والموجود أو الوعد حتى يمكن
نظريًّا وفقاً لـ«كريسبر» وقدرتنا لفهم كيف الحمض النووي شغّال
أننا نقدر نغير اللي أنا قلت عليه قبل شوي، صح؟
نقدر نغيّر شكل الإنسان قبل يولد؟
أيش اللي نقدر نسويه قبل ولادة الإنسان؟
نظريًّا؟
نظريًّا
أي شيء، نظريًّا
نظريًّا وفقًا للتقنية اللي واصلينها
إيه نعم
أن هذه التقنية اللي اليوم عندنا، قادرة على أنها أيش تسوي؟
لما تكلم عن الإنسان قبل يولد، أيش أقدر أغيّر؟
نظريًّا؟
نظريًّا
أي شيء
أي شيء، أي شيء؟
نظريًّا تقدر. شوف هي مثل ما قلت لك
هي أنك تكون عارف أيش هو الجين اللي أنت تبغاه
مثلًا أبغى عيون خضراء، أبغى الجيل القادم كل يكون عيونه خضراء
لازم تعرف الجين المسؤول عن لون القزحية
وأيش الجين المسؤول عن لون الأخضر بالتحديد
وبالتالي، أول شيء تعرف الطبيعي
وتعرف اللون الأخضر بالتحديد كيف يتم التكويد له أو شفرته
وبعد كذا ترسل «الكريسبر» عشان يغيّر اللون الموجود إلى لون الأخضر
نظريًّا إذا أنت عارف أيش هو الجين
أيش هو الطبيعي، وأيش الطفرة الحميدة اللي أنت تبغى تخلقها
طيب هم عارفين الآن أيش...
فيه أشياء كثير تم الإجابة عنها، فيه طبعًا...
لون العين منها؟
لون العين، لون البشرة، القوة البدنية
معظم الأمراض يعرفوا الشفرة الجينية حقها
مثل أيش؟
السرطان مثلًا، طبعًا السرطان كلمة كبيرة
لكن فيه أنواع كثير من السرطان معروف أسبابها الجينية
الأشخاص اللي عندهم الطفرة الجينية هذه
هم أكثر عرضة للمرض من غيرهم
فيه ناس يقول لك لا، ترى فيه حتى على مستوى الأمراض النفسية
فيه ناس عندهم توحّد مثلًا
بعض الناس بيتكلم عن جين مخصوص للتوحّد
فيه ناس بيتكلم عن اكتئاب
اللي عندهم الجين هذا أكثر؛ عرضة للاكتئاب
نجي نطلع مثلًا من الأمور النفسية
ندخل حتى في الأشياء الجسدية
السمنة، الطول، العرض، اللياقة، قوة القلب، قوة العضلات
قوة العظام، طبعًا قوة العظام أقصد كثافة العظام
هذه كلها اليوم صارت معلومة؟
الجينات اللي له علاقة فيها والمسؤول عنها معلومة إلى حد كبير
فعليًّا نقدر نعرف أن هذا الجين هو المسؤول عنه
ونقدر نعرف أن هذا هو العطب
إذا فيه عطب، نقدر نعرف أن فيه عطب اليوم؟
نظريًّا إيه، بس السؤال مو كذا
السؤال هل مُجدي أني أغيّر؟
إيه، ليش؟ أتوقع مُجدي، وللا؟
كم بتغيّر؟
ما أدري، لنفرض أن مثلًا السرطان
أنا عارف أن فيه مشكلة الآن وأقدر أغيّره وأخليه سليم
هل أغيّره وللا ما أغيّره؟
لحظة خليني أسحبك شوية وراء
على أساس الأمور تكون واضحة
يكون الجدلية في مكانها
فيه نوعين من التدخل الجيني
نوع ما بعد الولادة، ونوع على مستوى الحُيين والبويضة
اللي بعد الولادة لن أناقش فيه
سأناقش فيه بعدين
لا، للا بأس فيه، افعل ما بدا لك بعد الولادة
طالما أنه حسب الأدوات البحثية الأخلاقية اللي متعارف عليها
لا تجي خارج العداد، وتقول مثلًا ولد الطفل هذا بمشكلة إثنية
أنه طلع مثلًا أبيضاني في مجتمع أسمر، أو أسمراني في مجتمع أبيض
فأنا أبغى أغيّر لونه
لا، هنا أخلاقيًّا أقول لك سواءً «كريسبر» أو غير «كريسبر» ماهو مقبول
فطالما أنك تلعب في الأدوات الأخلاقية المسموح فيها بعد الولادة
استخدم «كريسبر» أو غير «كريسبر» عليك بالقوة
الحين فيه قدرتين للتعديل، فيه ما بعد الولادة وفيه ما قبل الولادة
ما قبل التلقيح
نعم
ما قبل التلقيح، تفضل
ما قبل التلقيح، يقول العلماء أنها قادرة على إحداث فروقات
في الأجيال كاملة، وليس في الشخص
لما قلت لك افعل ما بدا لك في ما بعد الولادة
فأنا أعلم أن كل اللي راح تسوي هذا؛ راح يكون مكانه الشخص
لكن لما تشتغل على المستوى الحُيين والبويضة
لا، أنت بتغيّر في النسل كامل
وإذا تلاعبت أو بدأت تسمح للعالم أو الطبيب
أن يتلاعب في أبجديات النسل؛ لا نعلم أين سوف نقف
أنا دائمًا بستخدم مثال في المحاضرات اللي بلقيها
وفي الأشخاص اللي يقول لك أن أنت ضد العلم
إطلاقًا. هل الفرامل ضد السواقة؟
إطلاقًا. أنت لو عندك سيارة من أجمل السيارات
ما بحط دعايات وأقول لك سيارتك كذا
من أجمل السيارات وأسرع السيارات في الكرة الأرضية
هندسة السيارة هذه بتعتمد على أشياء كثير
لكن أهم حاجتين
قوة المكينة، عدد الأحصنة اللي ممكن تستخدمها المكينة
والسرعة اللي ممكن توصلها
وقوة البريكات اللي موجودة فيها
لأن أنا لو أعطيت لك أجمل سيارة في الكرة الأرضية
وأسرع سيارة في الكرة الاراضية
بدون فرامل؛ أنا بحكم عليك بالموت
ادعس واستمتع 100، 120، 200، 300
تجي تبغى الفرامل في اللحظة اللي أنت محتاجها
هذا تابوت متحرك، وكذلك العلم
العلم إذا ما كان فيه الأدوات التي توقفه عند حدّه؛ فهو تابوت متحرك
عشان كذا نحن عندنا مشكلة كبيرة في التعديل الجيني على النسل
ما قبل البويضة، على ماهية البشرية كما نعرفها
إذا سمحنا لأحد أن يتلاعب فيها بأدوات ناقصة
ترى «كريسبر» ناقص
أيش ناقص؟
راح نتكلم عنها، بس خلني أكمل فكرتك
بأدوات ناقصة، فنحن لا نعلم أين سننتهي
أنا وأنت بكرة بنكون منبوذين اجتماعيًّا
ليش؟ لأن فيه جيل بيطلع، بيكون أسرع مني وأحسن مني
وأشطر مني وأذكى مني وأقوى مني وإلى آخره
وبالتالي أنا أصبحت على هامش البشرية
والبشرية انتقلت إلى البشرية ألف
ماهي بشرية، لا، بشرية ألف
شيء مختلف عن اللي بدأنا فيه.
بشرية ألف وراح تستمر بشرية باء
بشرية بلس
وهكذا، فهذا الغرور العلمي قد يقود الإنسان إلى الهاوية، إلى التهلكة
وبالتالي احنا ما نبغى العلم ينتقل
يتحول إلى التابوت البشري البشري كما نعرفها
نجي للسؤال إلى أنت سالتني هو، ليش «كريسبر» ماهو كامل؟
ترى الفلاسفة يحبوا يعطوا الألغاز هذه، فخلينا نلعب اللغز هذا
أفترض معاي قصر فيه كثير من التحف المنمنمات
اللي ممكن تتاخذ في الجيب، جواهر وأشياء جميلة
بس أنها ممكن تتأخذ في الجيب، وما أحد يدري عنها
لكن لكل قطعة قيمتها العالية في موروث الأمة هذه، صاحبة القصر
وصار فيه مشكلة داخل القصر وأصحابه ما هم موجودين
المشكلة هذه قد تؤدي إلى...
مثلًا مشكلة كهرباء وللا مشكلة بناء وللا ترميم
وللا انفجرت ماسورة موية جوّا
وما في طريقة أن تدخل أحد يعالج المشكلة هذه
قبل أن ينهدم القصر إلا شخص جسمه قلّيّل، يدخل من فتحة صغيرة
لكن الشخص هذا حرامي، سروق
لا تستطيع أن تتنبأ بما يمكن أن يفعل
لكن هو الشخص المناسب للدخول من المنطقة هذه
وعلاج مشكلتك اللي هناك، هل تخليه يدخل؟
يوتّر
هذا هو مشكلة الـ«كريسبر» الـ«كريسبر» أنه سروق
أنت بتدخّل هذا، أداة بهيمة بتقول لها
اقرأي يا هذه الأداة، هذه الطفرة أنا ما أبغاها
طيب التسلسل هذا، بالصورة هذه، في المكان هذا؛ مرض
وهنا يجي الجهل البشري
قد يكون التسلسل هذا نفسه في مكان آخر من الجينوم؛ ليس مرض
بس الأداة البهيمة هذه ما راح تعرف
راح تروح تغيّر لك اللي أنت تبغاه يتغير، واللي ما تبغاه يتغير
وبالتالي أنت بتغير اللي أنت تبغاه يتغير
وأشياء كثير ما تبغاها تتغير؛ قاعدة تتغير معاه
والمشكلة أنك لا تعلم ما الذي تغير
من المستحيل أنك تعرف أيش بالضبط «كريسبر» سوّى
تعرف جزء اللي أنت اخترت أنك تعرفه
واللي أنت برمجت الـ«كريسبر» أن يسويه
أنا أبغاك تدخل تغيّر لي كذا
طيب أنا بدخل أغيّر كذا، بس في الطريق بسوي اللي أنا أبغاه
بس مو دقته عالية؟
لا
نجي لتعريف الدقة، دقته عالية في الشيء اللي أنا أبغاه
روح اقرأ هذا الكود، متى ما تلقى هذا التسلسل؛ غيّره بالتسلسل هذا، كذا
بس الجينوم فيه تسلسلات كثير متشابهة
وبالتالي فيه تغييرات كثير غير مرغوبة
الآن فيه بحوث في جامعة «كاوس» في جامعة الملك عبدالله في «ثول»
أحد الباحثين، باحث قابلته قبل يومين، باحث ياباني
هو من كبار العلماء في المختبر هذا
هو دكتور «مو»
البحوث حقه كلها بتتركز على تخفيف الآثار
أو التغييرات الغير مرغوبة في «كريسبر»
فحتى الأشخاص اللي مندفعين في حب «كريسبر»
يعلمون أن «كريسبر» سروق، ما تقدر تسيطر عليه سيطرة كاملة
بعد ما يخلص؛ لازم يكون في عندك إمكانية أن توقفه عند حدّه
قبل ما يغيّر تغيرات أخرى ما نعرفها
الآن فين المشكلة؟
المشكلة لما تغيّر على مستوى النسل
أنت صح غيرت الشيء اللي أنت تبغاه
لكن أيش الناتج؟ أيش الشيء اللي أنت ما تعرف عنه وتم تغييره؟
قد يكون مثلًا الشخص هذا...
وأنا طرحت السؤال هذا على الدكتور «مو»
قلت له هل الأدوية اللي خرجت هذه تعتبر أدوية مأمونة
كانت إجابة واضحة جدًّا
قال لي أنت عندك الحين مرض
وهذا المرض يؤدي إلى حصول أزمة كل أسبوعين
لازم الشخص يدخل إلى المستشفى وياخذ علاجات مكثفة
وقد يؤدي إلى الإدمان، وقد يؤدي إلى مشاكل اجتماعية ثانية
في المقابل، أن عندك علاج ممكن يؤدي إلى أن بعد عشر سنوات
ما يدخل الطوارئ بسبب مرض مثلًا، الأنيميا المنجلية
ولكن بعد عشر سنوات ممكن يجي له سرطان
ممكن يجي له صرع، ممكن يجي له توقف في الدورة الدموية
ممكن يجي له قلب، ممكن يجي له أي شيء
ما ندري
ما نعرف، سروق
أوه!
فهنا المشكلة، الغطرسة العلمية اللي تسوّق للتقنية هذه
على أنها هي الحل لجميع مشاكل البشرية
أنا ضد الفكرة هذه
وفي المقابل أيضًا ضد الفكرة حق أنها تقنية ملعونة
ولا يجب أن تُلمس، وهي رجس من عمل الشيطان
لا أقول بذلك أنا، لكن أقول أن كل شيء يجب أن يكون فيه
قوة أحصنة عشان تندفع الإمام بقوة
وفيه فرامل تنجينا من الموت المحقق في الانعطافات الحرجة
بس الآن التطور العلمي برضه متسارع
فممكن نصل، خصوصًا مع وجود الذكاء الاصطناعي
ممكن نصل إلى قدرة عالية جدًّا ودقة مهولة
في تحديد بالضبط أيش اللي نبغى نوصله ونحدده
إذا وصلنا، الله يوفقنا
ما تستبعد وصولنا إلى هذه الفكرة؟
لا، ما أستبعد
خلينا نضع الأمور في نصابها
ابتعد عن الأحلام الوردية
ادرس الواقع كما هو
ابدأ صغيرًا ثم اكبر
لا تعِد الناس بأكثر مما تستطيع أن تُقدم
قدِّم الضرر قبل أن تقدم الوعد بالعلاج
وعندها أقول لك لما لا
مقارب بما بعد الولادة
أما في حالة التناسل؛ لا
حتى وإن وصلنا إلى أكثر دقة ممكنة، الإجابة لا
أخلاقيًّا، علميًّا، شرعيًّا
بجيها، بس مبدئيًّا ممكن نقول بعد عشر سنين
ممكن أن تكون عندنا التقنية الدقيقة جدًّا
وقادرة على تحديد كل شيء نبغاه
فما فيه خطأ، وما صار سروق
قدرنا أن نتحكم في أخلاقيات «كريسبر»
فنقدر نعرف أن «كريسبر» رايح هنا، وبيسوي هذا بالضبط
فنقدر نعرف أنه لو عدّل الجين
ما راح يجيه سرطان وصرع بعد عشر سنين، ممكن؟
ممكن
وعندها نقدر فعليًّا بس أخلاقيًّا، عشان أنا أبغى أدخل على الأخلاق
ودي أتأكد أيش اللي نقدر، أيش الممكن اللي بيكون وقتها
أن أنا أقدر وممكن أصمم الإنسان كما أريد
لا
أيش اللي أقدر أسويه وقتها؟
تعالِج المشاكل التي لا تعالَج إلا بهذه الطريقة
لا، بس إذا أنا جيت أخذتها على ما قبل البويضة
أقدر أختار لون، وأقدر أسوي كل شيء، صح؟
نظريًّا، لكن حتى لو استطعت بقول لك لا، لا تفعل
ما عليك، أنا بجي للا تفعل، أنا بجي للأخلاق بعد شوي
بس أبغى أتأكد الآن أيش اللي ممكن
فعليًّا، أقدر أسوي كل شيء، صح؟
أصمم طفلي كما أريد
نظريًّا تستطيع، فعليًّا قد لا تستطيع
بسبب مشاكل في التكنولوجيا نفسها
ممكن بعد عشر سنوات، أقول لك نعم يستطيعون بكل سهولة
لكن الآن فيه مشاكل في التكنولوجيا نفسها
بس أن بعد عشر سنوات، توقعي بنصل إلى القدرة هذه الدقيقة
قد
إيه، بعد عشر سنين، عندها ممكن أني أصمم الطفل كما أريد، صح؟
ذكاء محدد، طول معين، لون معين، قوة عضلات
إنسان خارق، أقدر أصممه
ممكن
صدق؟
وقتها إذا وصلنا للدقة هذه في «كريسبر»
أو غيرها من التقنيات اللي ممكن تطلع
في الإنسان الحي، أيش اللي أقدر أغيّره؟
اللي هو التعديل ما بعد الولادة
إذا وصلنا برضه للدقة العالية اللي نقدر نسويها
أيش اللي أقدر أغيّر فيه؟ أقدر أغيّر لون عيوني؟
طالما احنا نتكلم عن الخيال العلمي، أقدر أقول لك...
لا، مو خيال علمي
الواقع؟
الواقع إذا صار «كريسبر» دقيق
مجرد أنك تقدر تعالج الأمراض اللي يعاني منها الشخص
إذا استطعت مثلًا أنك تصل إلى الجين المسؤول عن الضغط
الجين المسؤول عن السكر في الشخص هذا بالتحديد
لأن الإنسان يختلف من شخص لشخص
وكل الأشياء المتعلقة بالطفرة الجينية
اللي تؤدي إلى أن الشخص هذا مثلًا يكون مريض سكر
أو مريض ضغط أو عنده مشاكل، أيًّ كان المشاكل اللي بيعانيها
في كل الأمراض؟
إيه نعم
القاتلة؟
نعم. غالب الظن أن اللي راح يصير بعد عشر سنوات
أن راح يعد العلماء صانعي القرارات
أن راح نقدر نسيطر على المرض
على طريقة مثلًا الأنيميا المنجلية، العلاج هذا اللي بـ 3 مليون
يمكن يجي واحد يقول أنا لدي علاج للضغط
عندي علاج للسكر، عندي علاج للحول، عندي علاج للقصر
عندي علاج للصلع، أنا عندي علاج للتقدم في العمر
أنا عندي علاج لأمراض الشيخوخة، الركب، الروماتيزيوم
الأمراض، وليس الطبائع البشرية
فالأمراض ممكن نوصل إلى أننا نحلها جينيًّا؟
هذا الحلم، هذا اللي بتشتغل على المختبرات كلها، كلٌ في مجاله
اللي بيشتغل على كذا واللي بيشتغل على كذا
على المستوى الجيني، عشان تجي بعد فترة من الفترات
بعد عشر سنوات، يقول أستطيع أن أتدخل طبيًّا
أو عن طريق إبرا أو عن طريق حبة أو عن طريق جهاز
يدخله الشخص من هنا مريض، ويخرج من هناك معافى، ممكن
بس ما تقدر تغيّر أي شيء في شكل الإنسان؟
عبثي هنا بيكون
هل أقدر وللا ما أقدر؟
نظريًّا ممكن
أيش اللي أقدر أغيّر؟
أثبتوا الآن أنهم يقدروا ينتجوا فأر أسرع من الفئران العادية
الآن فيه أبحاث، تقول أنهم أنتجوا فئران أسرع من الفئران العادية
قدروا يعالجوا بعض مشاكل الشيخوخة عند بعض الفئران
قدروا أنهم يغيروا قوة القلب اللي لها علاقة بسلامة الدورة الدموية
ففيه أشياء كثير تتعلق بالمظاهر، الآن يقدر يقول لك أنه...
بس هل التعديل تم بعد الولادة؟
هو باستخدام «كريبسر»
بس عشان أكون صادق ماني متأكد
بالفكرة، نقدر نغيّر بعد الولادة هذه الأشياء برضه؟
أمراض الشيخوخة؟
نظريًّا ممكن
لون البشرة؟ شعر؟ لون العين؟
هنا سأقف وأقول لك ما أعرف
أيش اللي يحدد؟ هل هي أنها...
لأن راح يكون عندك جين تم...
لما تقول أغيّر، معناته بالفعل عندك جين شغال
فإنك تغيّره، ماني متأكد من البيولوجية حقتها كيف راح تشتغل
طبعًا واللي يتم ما قبل الولادة يصبح جين قابل للتوريث
إيه نعم
فيورّث؟
إذا عدلته وصار معضل، ما يحتاج نعدل أولاده
خلاص إيه
فأنت بتغيّر في البشرية كلها؟
نعم
الحين هذا الممكن
الممكن والحلم
والحلم ليس بعيد، أنت تتكلم عن فكرة
ممكن
نجي الحين ليش لا، ليش ما نسويه؟
ما اللي يمنعنا أن نسوي كل هذا؟
احنا بنتكلم عن مرحلة الحُيّين والبويضة
الهوية الإنسانية ارتكزت على أشياء كثيرة
من ضمنها الهوية البيولوجية
والمشكلة أن هناك الكثير مما لا نعرفه
بكل تواضع يجب على الإنسان أن يقول أنا هنا لا أعرف
إذا كان هذا يعتبر نهاية بشرية أو بداية لشيء جيد
الهوية البشرية كما نعرفها
وبالتالي أي تدخّل في هذا الشيء الدقيق
يعتبر تدخّل جاهل، وفيه كثير من الغطرسة العلمية
التي تظن أنها تعلم ولا تعلم
نجي لموضوع روحاني شوية
نعلم أن بعد أربعين اثنين وأربعين يوم
تُنفخ الروح في الجنين ويصبح إنسان
ينتقل من كونه جنينًا عبارة عن تجمع خلوي إلى إنسان
الحين أنت أيها العالم اللي تبغى تسوي تحوير جيني
هل تستطيع أن تفسر هذه العملية؟
لا يستطيع. هنا قبل خمسة دقائق ما كان إنسان والآن إنسان
بالنسبة لنا، نزل الملك، ونفخ الملك فيه الروح
نعرفها عقيدةً، لكن هل نستطيع أن نعرف ماذا حصل
على المستوى البيولوجي دقةً؟ لا نعرف ولا نستطيع
يا رجل الموت ما نقدر نقول أن هذا مات، وهذا ما مات
لهذه الدرجة وصلنا
فيه غطرسة علمية تدّعي أشياء كثير ليست قادرة على حملها
و تدخل فيه الماهية الإنسانية
إذا أنا غير قادر على أني أقول فلان مات
طالما أنه يتنفس بأجهزة أو لا يتنفس بأجهزة
لا أستطيع أن أحكم بموته
تعريف الموت أصبح تعريف هلامي
تعريف الحياة أصبح تعريف هلامي
لكنها أشياء نعرفها وأشياء هي القيومة على ماهيتنا الإنسانية
هذا على المستوى الكوني، أو المستوى الإلهي
أو المستوى الروحاني، في من نحن
أن هذا كله يصير له عملية تقزيم أو تقليص
إلى عبث جيني علشان أطلّع حاجة محددة
وأنا قادر على أني أسيطر عليها
هذا أنا أعتقد أنه غير سليم
أنت قد تستطيع أن تغيّر أشياء محددة
لكن السؤال أكبر من التغيير في حد ذاته
علشان أطلّع شخص سليم أو أطلّع شخص قوي وأشياء حلوة
وشخص شعره طويل وإلى آخره
السؤال، ما الذي تغيره في الإعدادات البشرية
اللي تلعب في الماهية الإنسانية نفسها؟
إذا أنت غير قادر على أنك تجاوب
أيش اللي حصل قبل خمسة دقائق
من نفخ الروح من ناحية بيولوجية
وأيش اللي خلّى هذا إنسان أو غير إنسان
إذا أنت منت قادر
طبعًا المحايد راح يقول لك فعلًا
الإنسان غير قادر على تحديد أن هذا الشخص
توفى دماغيًّا أو لم يتوفى دماغيًّا، طبعًا فيه مؤشرات
لكن فيه أشياء كثير ممكن أنها تتحدى هذه المؤشرات
الغطرسة العلمية قد تقود الجنس البشري إلى نهايته
فهنا احنا مشكلتنا مع الغطرسة العلمية
نحب العلم وندعم العلم
ندين للعلم بأشياء كثيرة، نتمنى أن يتطور العلم
نتمنى أن نستطيع أن نركز الجهد على المشكلة وليس على الحلم
نتمنى أن يوفر المجادلون طاقتهم في الجدل النافع
ويتغير العداد الصحي إلى عداد أكثر صحيةً
بدل ما نفكر في الإنسان الخارق
طيب من اللي بيحدد أيش هو الإنسان الخارق؟ بناءً على أيش؟
اللحظة هذه الإنسان الخارق هذه مواصفاته
يمكن بعد عشر سنوات يختلف الإنسان الخارق
وإذا استطعنا أن نصل للإنسان الخارق هذا
راح يكون فئة قليلة القادرة على تحمّل التكاليف
اللي تؤدي للإنسان الخارق
وبالتالي سيتمايز المجتمع إلى مجتمع قادر ومجتمع غير قادر
مجتمع لديه الفرصة ومجتمع لا فرصة لديه
مجتمع ماليًّا مؤسس على أن يحصل على الابن الذكي
القوي، العظيم، الرهيب، الخارق
وطائفة اللي ينتهي أنه يشيل، الله يكرمك، الزبالة
والمهن التي لا يريد هذا الإنسان الخارق القيام بها
وما في مشكلة في أي مهنة
بس أنه ستتمايز مهن للصفوة ومهن لخَدمة الصفوة هذول
في الجانب الأول الروحاني أو الإلهي اللي أنت أخذته
نتفق عليه، لكن ودي أن نطلعه من النقاش
لأننا نتكلم عن العالم اللي لا يتفق على هذا بالضرورة
ففيه اختلاف ما بين ناس متدينة وناس غير متدينة
ناس بأديان مختلفة أو ناس ملحدة أو غيرها
فاللي كلهم يملكون نفس الأداء، ويمكن أن يسووها
ودي نتكلم على الواقع لي
مين يقدر يمنع؟
تقنية «كريسبر» يمديك تطلبها أنت تجيك
تقنية متاحة، وطبيعة التقنيات أن تصبح متاحة للجميع
حتى ليس على نطاق الدول، وإنما حتى على نطاق الأفراد
بس خلني أقعد على نطاق الدول
كيف ممكن أن الدول أصلًا تتفق على فكرة
تدرون، لا ما بنسويها
أيش اللي ممكن يصير؟
ممكن تجي دولة تقول أمريكا ما تبغى تسويها مثلًا
أنا ألمانيا بسويها، طز
وبكذا يصيرون الألمان، والألمان عندهم خبرة في الموضوع هذا
بس أن ينتقون عِرق معين وطريقة معينة
ويصممون أطفالهم ويصبحون هم أقوياء، أذكياء، عباقرة
والعالم كله جالس يتفرج
فمن يحكم الدول في أنها بتقول لا أنا ما أبغى
تدري، كلنا متفقين
الأخلاقيات
بتختلف الأخلاقيات؟
لا ما تختلف، أوه أنت دخلت في موضوع عظيم
اطلع بسرعة
ما تعتقد أن أخلاقياتنا مثلًا نحن المسلمين العرب
تختلف عن أخلاقيات الصينيين مثلًا؟
هل مثلًا عندنا القتل كويس وعندهم ماهو كويس؟
إيه
احنا عندنا الإعدام، والأمريكان يشوفونه غير أخلاقي
لا، هذه العقوبات، هذا موضوع آخر
تمام، بس أنا أقتل إنسان، لأني أشوف أن «وَلَكُمْ فِي الْقِصَاصِ حَيَاةٌ»
وهم يقولون لا، ليش تقتل الإنسان، أنت ترتكب غلط
أنا أتكلم عن القتل المجرد
الآن هل أستطيع أني أقول أنا متضايق من الأسئلة هذه
انتبه، الحين بطلّع سلاح و أثوّرك
هل يحق لي الكلام هذا؟ الجملة هذه؟
في العالم كله؟
أيوة
لا، بمشي معك
وحيث أنه قدرنا نكوّد قيمة أخلاقية محددة، الجميع يتفق عليها
نجي للهوامش هذه، دائمًا فيه اختلافات في الهوامش
معليش، بتراجع عن إجابتي
لأن النقاش أخلاقي، اليوم يمكن متفقين
بس قبل كم سنة ما كنا متفقين
عادي فيه ناس اللي يقتل هو البطل، صح؟
بدون سبب؟
كذا لأن هو قوي. صدق إذا أخذناه في الشكل القديم في كل العالم
الإنسان راعي البقر اللي يقدر يستخدم...
لا. حتى في هذاك المجتمع كان فيه حرمة للدم
حرمة الدم هذا شيء لا جدال فيه
نأتي إلى ما يمكن أن يسمو على حرمة الدم
ممكن القصاص مثلًا عندنا
في هذاك الزمن عند رعاة البقر كان مثلًا الأنفة
أن أنت تحديتني؛ أنت بتدفع بالدم
بالتالي، ما يجي واحد مثلًا جالس في مطعم
وللا على طريقة رعاة البقر في البارات
ويجي فجأة يثوّر بالمسدس
ما تجي، لازم فيه مقدمات تُحل الدم
وبالتالي إذا قلنا أن ما كان عندهم قيمة حرمة الدم
عادي يدخل، أعطيني كأسًا من الشعير
بس ما تتفق أن مثلًا المسلمين أيش سووا؟
قالوا أن الدم مثلًا في القصاص يجب أنك كذا كذا
فإذا أنت قتلت؛ احنا بنقتلك، أو ممكن حتى تعزيرًا نقتلك
لأن لي حماية المجتمع، فهم قرروا أن هذا الشكل
بينما هناك، لو أنك ما عجبتني، تعال خل نطلع برّا ويلا
ففيه بون واسع ما بين أيش اللي نقتل، بس أن كلهم يقتلون
فيختلف الأخلاقيات، الإسلام رفعها جدًّا، بينما هذولا عادي
أنت تتكلم في الهوامش، متى يحل الدم
أنت أيش تبغى تقول؟
أنا أبغى أقول بصورة عامة، أن الدم محرّم عندنا وعندهم
فيه مقدمات تُحل الدم
عندنا الشرع قال كذا كذا
عندهم الشخص القوي قال كذا كذا
بس لا عندنا ولا عندهم، أن ما عجبني السؤال؛ بقوم بذبح اللي سألني
كذا، وأطلع منها بدون عواقب
فيه أفلام كثير انتشرت على الفكرة الأخلاقية
أن راح نجوّز القتل لمدة اثنا عشر ساعة
مثلًا من الساعة 6:00 إلى الساعة 6:00
افعل ما أردت، اقتل من تريد
وبعدها خلاص راح يتطهر المجتمع من أثامه
بس أهم شيء عندك الستة ساعات هذه افعل ما تريد
لا يوجد عاقل على سطح البسيطة يدافع عن فكرة مثل هذه
لأن الدم حرام
أيش أخذنا للحديث هذا؟
أن هل الدول بتتفق على...
أيوة، الكود الاخلاقي الموحد
فيه ما وراء الأخلاقيات، الأخلاقيات علم واسع
ما وراء الاخلاقيات، هذا السؤال تقريبًا جاوبوا عليه باستفاضة
نحن نتفق كبشر على القيم العظمى
لكن نختلف في تفسير هذه القيم
ممكن أجيب لك أمثلة كثيرة
لكن دائمًا اللي يدرس فلسفة أو الأخلاقيات
يحبوا يصدموا بفكرة قاسية
يقول اللي يرى أن هناك اختلاف في القيم ما بين المجتمع والمجتمع
خذها على سبيل المثال، ثقافة الإسكيمو
ثقافة الإسكيمو كان قبل حوالي عشرات السنوات
دائمًا استخدم المثال هذا، وقد أكون استخدمته في بودكاست ثاني
فاللي سمعه قبل كذا يتحملني قليلًا
فقط للرد على معرض السؤال
كان طريقة التخلص أو طريقة الدفن
أو طريقة التعامل مع جثمان الشخص الذي يتوفى
خاصةً إذا كان كبير في السن هو أكل لحمه
بالنسبة لهم هذه قيمة، هم يعتقدون أن الأرواح تتركز في اللحم هذا
وبالتالي عملية التهام اللحم هذه تنقل هذه الأرواح
والموروث الثقافي إلى أجسامهم
وبالتالي هم حاملينها حتى يأتي من بعدهم يأخذ هذه وإلى آخره
حتى اليوم الإسكيمو في نفسهم ينفرون من هذه الفكرة
التهام لحم الميت، وتصبح بالنسبة لهم غير أخلاقية
هل تغيرت الأخلاق، أم تغير تعريف هؤلاء الأشخاص لما هو أخلاقي؟
القيمة لا تزال هي القيمة، إكرام الميت
هذه القيمة الآن الأساس
نحن نرى أن إكرام الميت كما الله، سبحانه وتعالى، أمرنا
الجبلّة المحمدية هي السنة أن يدفن بالصورة المحددة
ولا توجد أكثر من صورتين في الدفن، لحد أو شقّ
ما في غيرهم إذا كان الشخص مسلم
ما لم يكن هناك ضرورات أخرى، غرق حرق إلى آخره، هذه أمور أخرى
لكن إذا استطعنا أن نثبّت الجسد المتوفى
يجب أن يتم إكرامه ودفنه بهذه الطريقة
بالنسبة للأشخاص اللي يرون إحراق الجسد
هم يرون أن هذا نوع من أنواع الإكرام
وبالتالي نتفق على القيمة ونختلف في تفسير القيمة هذه
المجموع البشري متفق على قيم
لكنه قد يختلف في عملية تفسير القيم هذه
هذا أرجّعك لموضوع، ليش ما تجي مثلًا دولة إكس
وتقول أنا راح أسمح بـ«كريسبر»
علشان أنا أبغى الجيل حقي يكون خارق
لأن نفس هؤلاء مرتبطين اتفاقًا وقولًا واحدًا على القيمة
أن يجب عدم العبث بالموروث البشري
طالما أن احنا ما عندنا إجابة على الأسئلة الكبرى
لا نتلاعب بأشياء لا نعلم نتائجها
ومن يجرؤ أن يقول مثلًا علنًا
شوف هنا عشرة خطوط تحت كلمة علنًا
ويدعمها على رؤوس الأشهاد
فيه ناس كثيرة قد يكونون شغالين فيها سرًّا
ما نعرف أيش ممكن يسووا
لكن أنا بتكلم على رواية علنًا
ويتكلم بها على رؤوس الأشهاد
هؤلاء راح يكونوا محل احتقار العالم
ولا يتوجد جهة في الكرة الأرضية
تبحث على أن تكون محل احتقار عالمي
من ناحية علمية، من ناحية أخلاقية، من ناحية اقتصادية، لا
مكان مؤلم جدًّا، لا يريد أي أحد أن يكون هناك
حتى لو كانت النتيجة أن بيكون عندي أحسن جيش في الكرة الأرضية
بس ليش افترضت أنه بيكون محل احتقار العالم؟
لأن جميعنا نتفق على أن لا تعبث بالإنسان
هنا كلامك صحيح ومنطقي
بس لو تجي تطالع الحين مثلًا في أمريكا
هذا هم يسوون أشياء اليوم ما يقبلها العقل أصلًا
وما أحد يشوفها بهذا الاحتقار، وماشيين
من مبدأ الحرية الشخصية للإنسان
مثل أيش؟ أعطيني مثال
أنت بتدخلني في متاهة، أو أنا دخّلت نفسي، والله ما أعرف
والله أنت حاطني في متاهة من يوم ما بدينا
خلني أضغطك شوي
لا، اللي هي سالفة أن أنا ذكر وللا لا؟
ويدخلوا فيها ولا...
الهوية الجنسية
الهوية الجنسية، واللي يبغى يغير؛ يغير
واللي ما يبغى يغير؛ ما يغير
واللي يبغى يعترف بس يقرر أنه يغير غيّر، عادي
خلاص أصبحت كذا سائلة جدًّا هذه الهوية الجنسية
وعادي ما أحد يحتقر، تحتقرها أنت ما تحتقرها
الموضوع بسيط، بس بالنسبة للعالم عادي
بالعكس، هذا من باب الحريات وارتفاع الحريات الشخصية للناس
طيب نقطتك؟
النقطة أن ما أحد احتقر أمريكا
أنت عطيتني صورة أن كل الناس بيقولوا... لا، عادي سووها
ومو حتى هم، هم وأوربا وكلهم؛ فما فرق
يمكن أن الغرب يحتقرها إذا الصين سوتها،  لأن احنا ما سويناها
بس هم لو سووها؛ ما بيشوفونها احتقار
فما عندي هذا التصور اللي أنت رسمته
أنه بيصبح منبوذ أو محتقر، هذه نقطتي
كلمة الغرب كلمة كبيرة جدًّا
داخل الغرب هناك تيارات كثير متصارعة حتى الهوية الجنسية
الآن أكثر شيء تم طرحه بقتال شديد جدًّا هو الهوية الجنسية
وتمييع الهوية الجنسية ما بين أفراد المجتمع
أنا أقدر أقول أني أنثى وخلاص، ولازم تقول لي «حضرتك»
لازم ولا ترى أدخلك في الجدار وأرفع عليك قضية
وفي المقابل، فيه ناس كثير ضد الفكر هذا والتوجه
الآن من هو الذي صوته أعلى؟
صوته أعلى اللي هم اليساريين
اللي يرون بالحريات على أقصى أقاصيها
ومن ضمنها حرية ادّعاء الجنس
فلما نقول الغرب دفع فيها، نحن غير دقيقين
بمعنى أن الغرب فيه يسار وفيه يمين
اليساريين الغربيين، أو بالأصح متطرفي اليسار الغربي
هم الذين يدفعون بكل قوة في اتجاه تمييع الجنس
مش لتمييع الجنس، ولو نبغى كمان نكون منصفين
والإنصاف هنا عملة صعبة جدًّا
هم يدّعون الحرية بأقصى أقاصيها، الليبرالية بأقصى أقاصيها
وهذا فرض عليهم أن أنا حر في...
إذا أنا أبغى أصير ماني منافق في الحريات
وأعطيك الحرية؛ بكيفك
ثم دخل موضوع عملية الاحتقار
وأنا والآخرين والأقلية المستضعفة والماركسية
كل المعسكر اليساري بكامله يتحرك
فأخذ الموضوع نكهة الآيديولوجية، وليس البيولوجيا
خرجت البيولوجيا من الشباك في الموضوع هذا، ودخلت الآيديولوجية
دخلت الآيديولوجية؛ خلاص أصبح الموضوع غير خاضع للنقاش العقلاني
بل يدخل في النقاش العقدي السياسي
العقدي الديني، العقدي المنهجي، إلى آخره
خرجت البيولوجيا تمامًا من أوسع بواب النقاش هذا
فحتى في الغرب، هناك مدارس تجرّم الميوعة الجنسية هذه
فلا أتفق معك لما قلت أن الغرب
على قلب رجل واحد متفقون على التمييع
والاختلاف الشديد، بس أتفق معك على أن الصوت الأعلى
هم اللي عندهم الأداة الإعلامية، اللي عندهم الأداة السياسية
اللي عندهم الأداة الأكاديمية
والسيطرة تبدأ من الجامعات
اللي عندهم الأداة الأكاديمية اللي هم اليساريين، والتعاطف
أنا أذكر أني حضرت محاضرة فلسفية في إحدى الجامعات البريطانية
لأحد فلاسفة اليسار، أحد الفلاسفة الماركسيين
على الرغم من أنه في قلب مدينة رأسمالية
في دستورها الكيان رأسمالي بحت
وقائم الاقتصاد على الرأسمالية
وقائم الاقتصاد على الأدوات اللي هذا الشخص كان بينادي ضدها
ورغم ذلك كان المسرح مليء جدًّا
وكانت منقولة على ثلاثة قنوات
وكان لها حضور كبير جدًّا
قد يكون اسم الشخص من الأسماء المشهورة في المجال هذا
لكن اللي أبغى أقوله لك، هو كيف أن اليسار هو الذي يقود الجامعات
وكيف أن قيادة الجامعات هي اللي تقود الاقتصاد
هي اللي تقود السياسة، هي اللي تقود الإعلام
هي اللي تقود تغيير التبعات لبعض الأمور
أو محاولة تغيير القيم الليبرالية مثلًا
فأرجع أقول لك، اختلف معك أن الكل متفق
وأتفق معك أن الصوت الأعلى هم الصوت اليساري
المسيطر على المنابر الإعلامية، المنابر السياسية، المنابر الاقتصادية
فلو بناخذ هذه الفكرة، ونقول أن اليسار مجتمع الحريات إلى أقصاها
إلى مثلًا في الميوعة الجنسية
المنطقي مع اليسار أن يمشي في الحريات إلى أقصاها
فيقول إذا الأب والأم قرروا أنهم يغيرون الجين للطفل؛ فهم أحرار
إذا الإنسان قد يبغى يغير في اللي يبغاه؛ فهو حر
بيمشون مع فكرتهم، يطّردون معها
فمنطقيًّا أن هذا اللي بيحصل
أو إذا أنا بمشي مع فكرتك أو بطّرد معها
لما نغيّر الجنس أو لما أدّعي أن أنا أنثى وأنا ذكر
أو أنا ذكر وأنا أنثى، أو لما أدّعي بحرية من الحريات
هذه حرية شخصية، وبالتالي هنا أن أنا ضرري أو نفعي على نفسي
يخرج الإطار الفلسفي لتأطير موضوع التأثير حق التقنية
أو الزعم اللي أنا بزعمه
اللي يتغير تمامًا لما أتكلم عن من سيأتي مستقبلًا
أعطيك مثل، قصة مشهورة في الأخلاقيات تدرّس
أن أب وأم يعانون من عدم المقدرة على السماع، الصمم، كلاهما أصم
فراحوا للطبيب يبغوا يسووا تقنية الزراعة بانتخاب
من سيكون طفلًا من ناحية الانتخاب الجيني
للبويضة التي تحمل احتمالية أن يكون الطفل مصابًا بالصمم
بمعنى يبغوا يختاروا الطفل المصاب
طفلهم القادم يكون أصم، حتى يشاركهم الحياة اللي يبغوها
السؤال الآن، إذا رجعنا للحريات، هل يحق لهم ذلك؟ هم أحرار
الإجابة لا، لأن فيه شخص ثالث بيعاني من الموضوع هذا
اللي هو الطفل، والطفل هذا ليس فقط هو من سيعاني
بل سوف يحمل اللعنة، إذا جاز تسميتها كلعنة، إلى أجيال بعده
بس مثلًا اليوم أن أنا أختار جنس الطفل متاح؟
نعم
وأخلاقي؟
فيه حدود
وموجود في كل مكان، أي مستشفى
مش في كل مكان، بس موجود ومتاح
وعندنا في بعض المستشفى يسوونه
قصدي لأنه صار عادي، وأقدر أسويه
فأنت قدر تقول أن أنت تبغى تختار الطفل
فأنت فعلًا اخترت من يكون على الوجود
اخترت تبغاه أنثى أو ذكر، أنت تدخلت في هذا الاختيار
بينما تقدر تقول لا حرام، الله اللي يختار لي
اليوم موجود، لأنه صار تمام، سهل، رخيص نسبيًّا
و آمن إلى حدٍ ما، فيه بعض المشاكل، بس آمن
فيه ناس تعودت عليه وأصبح عادي
ماذا يمنع عندما يكون التعديل الجيني
أن الناس تبدأ تغيّر هذه الأشياء ويصبح طبيعي
ما قدرت أستوعب أن تجريمك الأخلاقي لها
أنت تشوف أنه مو أخلاقي عادي
بس أنك تتوقع أن الناس بتمشي مع منظومتك الأخلاقية، هنا إشكالي
خليني أوضّح الموضوع
أنا ما عندي مشكلة في اختيار جنس الجنين
ليه؟
بضوابطه
أيش ضوابطه؟
نعم، بضوابطه
مثلًا في الصين، عندهم سياسة الطفل الواحد أو الطفلين
حتى سمعت أنهم أصبحوا ثلاثة الآن، ماني متأكد
قال لي شخص غير موثوق في آخر زيارة لي في الصين
قال لي أنهم زادوا العدد، فما عندي توثيق للموضوع
نفترض أن دولة من الدول عندها سياسة الطفل الواحد
أنت تجيب طفل واحد، ويا ويلك لو تجيب طفل ثاني
أبغى ولد وللا بنت؟
الولد بيساعدني في الشؤون الرجالية، يشيل ويحط
وإذا مرضت يسعفني؟ وقوي وعظيم
وللا بنوتة أمورة تنتبه عليّ، تشيلني لما أكون تعبان
هي اللي جالسة وهي اللي ما من وراها إلا كل خير
راح اختار مين؟ وليش؟ هنا الضوابط
هل إذا أنا أجبرت الناس على أنه ما يكون عندهم إلا طفل واحد
أدخل ثاني مضطر، لأنه المجتمع عنده تفضيلات
تفضيلات بينهم
التفضيل مثلًا في المجتمع العربي أبغى ولد
علشان يشيل الاسم، وعلشان الميراث
وبالتالي إذا أنا عندي الخيار؛ أبغى ولد
أيش بيصير في المجتمع لما كله يصير أولاد؟ مصيبة
وبالتالي أنت لأنك تدخلت بصورة غير طبيعية على شيء طبيعي
مضطر أنك تجبر أن 50% ذكور و50% إناث
طيب، الـ 50% ذكور مين اللي بيحددهم؟
اللي عنده واسطة؟ وللا اللي عنده فلوس؟
طبعًا على فرض أن المجتمع يبغى ذكور
نفس الشيء ممكن أقوله على الإناث
مين اللي بيحصل بأن يكون عنده هالأمورة الغنوجة
اللي يقدر يطلّع معاها كل الأحاسيس العاطفية
اللي ما يقدر يطلعها مع الأقشر ولده
اللي ممكن يعطي له في جبهته وهو نايم، وإلى آخره
مين اللي راح يختار الأفضلية حقي؟
هل إذا أنا كنت غني؟
هل إذا كنت من الأشخاص المخوّلين بالتجربة وإلى آخره
وبالتالي، لازم أدخل في درجة ثالثة من درجة الحوكمة
أتأكد أن أول حاجة أجبرتك أنه ولد
ثاني حاجة أجبرك لازم 50% 50%
ثالث حاجة أتأكد أن اختيار 50% و 50% هذه كان عادل
وبعد كذا تسوي حوكمة
شايفت كيف التعقيد اللي في الموضوع؟
الموضوع اللي بيولوجي اللي اثنين يتزوجوا
في ليلة الدخلة يكتب ما كتب الله بينهما
وثم يخرجون بعد تسعة شهور للعالم بطفل الجديد
بدون أي نوع من أنواع التدخلات
أصبح مؤسسة من الأنظمة والأخلاقيات
وافعل ولا تفعل، وانتبه هنا ولا تدخل هناك
أصبح فيه تغوّل عظيم للتقنية
في هذه العلاقة البسيطة أم تسعة شهور
هنا نرجع للتنظيم، أنا ما عندي مشكلة في الاختيار
إذا على سبيل المثال، أسرة عندها أنيميا منجلية
جاء فحص ما قبل الزواج، قال أنتوا ما تصلحوا لبعض
بس فيه قيم أعلى من القيم الطبية
تخلينا أن احنا لازم نتزوج، سواءً لأن هذه بنت عمه
هو فرصتها الوحيدة أو هي فرصته، وإلى آخره
أو لأنه آخر شخصين في الكرة الأرضية هذول الاثنين
لازم يتزوجوا الحفاظ على النسل
أي نوع من أنواع الأسباب اللي ممكن تقول
أن هذول الاثنين لازم يتزوجوا، بعض النظر أيش السبب
نجي للتقنية الوراثية لعملية انتخاب الطفل الأنسب، سواءً ذكر أو أنثى
بس الأنسب من ناحية البيولوجية أن ما عنده مشكلة أنيميا المنجلية
أو مثلًا أسرة عندها سبعة أولاد ويبغوا بنت
أسرة عندها سبعة بنات ويبغوا ولد
هذه الضوابط تخليني أقول هم جايبين جايبين
فما فيه شيء يخليني أدخل في المحظور
حق أن لا هم يبغوا ولد علشان جنس الولد نفسه
نوع من أنواع التعنصر ضد...
بس الواقع اليوم أنه يمديك، ما في هذه الضوابط
يمديك تسوي اللي تبغاه
لا، فيه ضوابط
إلى اليوم؟
إيه، فيه ضوابط
أيش الضوابط مثلًا؟
مثل ما قلت لك إذا تبغى...
تقول لك أيش تبغى تختار، فيه ضابط أنك تدفع الفلوس
ماهي متاحة بالصورة... ليس الأمر من يدفع أكثر
إلا في الخارج عاد أنا ما أعرفه
إلا، أعتقد فيه السعودية أن تكلفتها يمكن حدود 25 ألف أو 20 ألف ريال
وفيه مستشفيات تسويها
بس حتى المستشفيات هذه ما تسويها بدون سبب موثّق
أتوقع رغبة بس، أنا ودي ذكر أو ودي أنثى
حسب الأنظمة اللي موجودة غير متاح
والله؟
نعم، لازم يكون فيه سبب
فيه بعض الأمراض ذكورية، مثلًا إذا جاء ذكر
راح يكون عنده حتمًا المرض الفلاني
أنا أعرف عائلة أن إذا جاهم ذكر يجي فيه مرض
ناسي أيش اسم المرض، بس إذا جات أنثى تجي سليمة
وبالتالي، ممكن يجي يقول لك أنا ما أبغى ولد
عشان ما أبغى المرض هذا
عودة على التعديل الجيني
في أمريكا غير مجرّم، فيمدي أي شركة تروح تسويه
كلام كبير مرة
أي تلاعب في ما قبل التلقيح؛ يعتبر غير مرحّب به عالميًّا
غير مرحّب فيه وللا مجرّم؟
مجرّم
مجرّم؟
مجرّم نعم
جريمة؟
بس طبعًا عشان كذا أنا حريص في المصطلح، مجرّم أخلاقيًّا
لا، إذا أخلاقيًّا مو مشكلة
بس ما راح أقدر أسجنك
بس أقدر أسويه لشركتي؟
إيه، بس ما راح تقدر تسوّق
إذا دخلت في موضوع التسويق؛ راح تدخل في موضوع التجريم القانوني
إذا دخل في موضوع جني الأموال من وراء الفكرة
اللي فيها عدم مقبولية من اللجان الأخلاقية؛ تدخل في تجريم
من أي ناحية؟
على سبيل المثال...
إذا أنا سويت اليوم مختبر تعديل جيني في أمريكا تتوقع بيصير ممنوع؟
أتوقع لا، وفقًا للي أعرفه على الأقل
هل تعديل جيني بحثي وللا تعديل جيني نهائي للزبون؟
لا، تجاري
ما يستطيع شخص في الكرة الأرضية الآن يفعلها
والله؟
ما يستطيع
ليش؟ أيش القانون اللي يمنعك؟
علشان تصل إلى تقديم شيء على مستوى البشر
يجب أنك تثبت مليون إثبات، احنا ترى في البدايات
وعندنا مشكلة في البدايات
أعطيك مثل قريب
العلاج بخلايا المنشأ، الخلايا الجذعية
الآن فيه بعض المراكز في العالم تدّعي أنها تعالج بخلايا المنشأ
وأشوف دعاياتها، العلاج بالخلايا الجذعية
فيه بعض الكريمات، الآن يقول لك الكريمات هذه
فيها خلايا جذعية تسوي مش عارف أيش
فيه بعض الادعاءات أن خذ هذه الإبرة وخلاص تعالج السكر
وفيه اللي ناعم، دعاية جدّد شبابك
تعال بس خذ لك منتج أبو خمسة أو ستة أيام
وفيها كم فعالية من ضمنها الشراب
وفيه ناس يقول لك والله كانت من أفضل ما يكون
هذول الأشخاص اللي فتحوا الباب على مصراعيه للناس بصورة نهائية
يستخدموا أدوات غير أخلاقية في التسويق، غير علمية
شوف أنت بتتكلم عن الجين
أعقد عشرات المرات من خلايا المنشأ
لأن خلايا المنشأ خلاص الخلية موجودة عندك
نحن ما نقدر، إذا أعطيت شخص خلايا جذعية
لا أعرف، الحين خلية الجذعية خلية بلا هوية
ولها القدرة على أنها تتمايز إلى خلية عظم
خلية عين، خلية عصب، خلية شعر، خلية أيًّ كان
خلية غير متمايزة
ما هو الشيء اللي يسبّب آثار للخلية هذه
أن تصير خلية عصب أو خلية عظم أو خلية...
ماهو كلها واضحة، ماهي كلها معروفة
قد يأتي واحد مثلًا يقول أنا بعطيك إبرة خلايا جذعية
وراح تعالج لك خلايا «لانجرهانس» اللي في البنكرياس
وبالتالي الإنسولين أصبح من التاريخ
طيب إذا وصلت الخلايا هذه البنكرياس
وتمايزت إلى خلايا عظم أو إلى خلايا سرطان؛ مصيبة
وبالتالي أنا أقول هذولا اللي فاتحين مراكز
يبيعوا الوهم، غير مؤسسين علميًّا
هذا أمام الناس، لكن لما نجي للتقنية اللي بيستخدموها
قد لا تكون علاج بالخلايا الجذعية بتعريفها
قد يكون مثلًا يستخدم شيء مخفف
شيء مثلًا ما له علاقة
يكذب على الناس بصورة أو بأخرى
لأن متى ما استخدم تقنية غير مأمونة
مأمونة الاستخدام على الجنس البشري؛ دخل في التجريم مباشرةً
ما بالك أن واحد يجي يفتح مختبر يقول
تعالوا أنا بسوي لكم تعديلات جينية
عجيب والله
طيب الله يعطيك العافية
شكرًا لكم، شكرًا لعمر الشنقيطي في إعداد الحلقة
خلف الكاميرات وهاب موسى
وفي التسجيل الصوتي عبدالعزيز المزي
والهندسة الصوتية محمد الحسن
والتحرير محمد نور شمّت
وفي التلوين عبدالمجيد العطاس
وفي إدارة محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي نورة السبيعي
ومنتج البرنامج أيمن الحمّادي
وفي إدارة التحرير أسيل با عبد الله
هذا فنجان، أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الإنتاج بحب من مدينة الرياض
الأسبوع المقبل؛ ألقاكم
هل غطينا كل النقاط اللي في بالك؟
لا، أنا توقعت البداية بتكون عن علم الأخلاقيات نفسها
لأن الآن حتى على مستوى صناع القرار، فيه جدل
هل نحتاج علم أخلاقيات؟
هل نحتاج واحد مثل عبدالله عدلان، يقول افعل أو لا افعل؟
نحتاجه 100%
خصوصًا الحين مثل السيارات برضه، إذا طلعنا عن الجينات
مثل السيارات ذاتية القيادة
دوبي عرفت أن الظاهر «إيلون ماسك» قرر
أو أن السيارة الحين لما تسوق، فهي تسوق لوحدها
اللي هي سالفة القطار
القرار الأخلاقي، نعم
الحين عندك ناس، عندك قطار، عندك هذا
قرار «إيلون ماسك» أنك أنت اللي تموت، اللي في السيارة
أخلاقي، طيب من اللي يموت؟
أنا ما أبغى، اقتل اللي على الطريق، ليش أنا أموت؟
المشكلة في الأتمتة
بالعكس، أحس أن الآن في عز الحاجة لعلم الأخلاقيات
مشكلة الأخلاقيات بصورة عامة هي مشكلة اصطلاحية بحتة
ماذا نعني عندما نقول أخلاقيات؟
وهذا النقاش جرى مع بعض صناع القرار
على مستوى مشرفين لصناع قرار أكبر
يقول لك أن أنا ما أحتاج أحد يقول لي الصح والغلط
أنا مؤسس أخلاقيًّا، أنا أعرف الصح والغلط
أنا عندي القانون، عندي الشريعة
ليش محتاج واحد متخصص في «الفلسفة الأخلاقية»
ومتخصص في«أخلاقيات علم الأحياء» عشان يقول لي هذا صح وهذا غلط
فأنا وجهة نظري أن عندنا مشكلة في تحرير المصطلح نفسه
كلمة أخلاق أضرّت ...
أيش المصطلح الأفضل؟
فيه كثير بيحاولوا يجابوا على السؤال هذا
في بعضهم سماها إيتقا مثلًا عملية نحت عربي أو تعريب لـ«Ethics»
بس أن اللغة العربية ممكن تكون أعمق من مجرد أن ننحت لها كلمة
لكن الفكرة هي أن استخدام كلمة أخلاق
يستدعي الخجل من إطلاق الأحكام
إذا قلت أن هذا غير أخلاقي
كأني بقول لا تسوي كذا لأسباب أخلاقية
كأني بقول أن أنت ما عندك أخلاق
كنا بنفكر في مشروع طُرح، وطبعًا ما مشى
أن يكون فيه على طريقة مثلًا شهادة
أو ختم جودة إن صح التمثيل، للمستشفى أو لمقدم الخدمة الصحية
أنه متماشي مع أفضل كود أخلاقي
بس أيش بتقول لو هذا أخذ وهذا ما أخذ
هذا أخلاقي وهذا غير أخلاقي؟
المصطلح هذا غير عادل
فهذا استدعى كثير من المشاكل في تحرير ماهية الأخلاقيات
وكيف ممكن الأخلاقيات تدعم القرار الطبي
الأخلاقيات بكل بساطة
نفرّق أول شيء بينها وبين الشرع
الشرع هو ما نفعله تعبّدًا لله سبحانه وتعالى
ويدخل في كل شيء من يوم ما تصحى إلى يوم ما تنام
في كل شيء يدخل
لكن مساحة الحلال كبيرة جدًّا
أنا علشان أقول والله استخدام الكأس هذا حلال
ما لم تضع فيه خمرًا؛ يصبح الكأس بما فيه محرمًا
هذا الاستثناء هو الشيء البسيط هو الحلال والحرام
لكن استخدام الكأس مساحة كبيرة جدًّا فيها مساحة الحلال
هل يعتبر ديانةً أني ما أحط في الكأس هذا عصير؟
واحنا متعارفين أن هذا كأس ماء؟
ما حد يستطيع يقول
لكن حسب التعارف هذا كأس ماء
فلو جبت لك فيه عصير، راح تقول شكرًا
بس ما هكذا تورد الإبل
أو لو حطيت القهوة في كأس شاهي أو الشاي
راح تكون مستهجن جدًّا
ماهو حرام
فعلم الأخلاقيات هو العلم اللي يدرس مساحة ما يجب وما لا يجب
بعد ما ننتهي من موضوع الحلّية والحُرمية
نأتي للفرق بينها وبين القانون
القانون هو بيستفيد من علم الأخلاقيات في تجريم ما يجب أن يُجرّم
على سبيل المثال، الموافقة المستنيرة
لما تروح إلى المستشفى ويقول لك، بنسوي فيك كذا وكذا
أنت موافق؟ موافق، يلا وقّع
إذا دخلت وأخذت إجراء
لنقل إجراء فيه عملية أو فيه تعدي على السلامة الجسدية
بصورة عامة بدون ما يقال
أقدر طبعًا أدخلها شرعًا أنها محرمة، من باب الضرر وكذا
لكن إذا ما استحضرت نية الضرر؛ ما تعتبر حرام
أن هذا الإجراء الطبيعي، أنت وثقت فيني وفي علمي
أنا أشوف أن لو جاء ولدي وعنده المشكلة هذه؛ راح أسوي له الإجراء هذا
بالتالي طلع من موضوع الشرع، لكن دخل في موضوع الأخلاقيات
لا، يجب أنك تعطي الشخص هذا الموافقة المستنيرة
أو الموافقة الدافعة للجهالة بالصورة اللي احنا بنتفق عليها
خالفت الآن؛ الأخلاقي بيقول أنت خالفت
يأتي القانوني يجرّم المخالفة هذه حسب تبعاتها
فهذه الفروقات اللي نعاني بها نحن كمتخصصين في علم الأخلاقيات
جزء منها بسبب المصطلح
وجزء منها بسبب عدم الوعي الكامل بماهية العلم
هو عبارة عن أدوات بسيطة تساعدني على تحرير الموقف
وإعطاء رأي قيمي في ما يراد أن يكون
ومن ضمن القيم التي نحاول حمايتها
حماية المجتمع من التغوّل الطبي
وحماية المجتمع الطبي من التغوّل المجتمعي أيضًا
يجيك واحد يدخل على الطبيب في بيته
ويتوقّع أن الطبيب راح يقدّم له جميع الخدمات الطبية
من استشارات، من خدمات
نحن ما نقول بذلك، كما أن ما نبغى الطبيب يدخل بيتي
ويقول لك أنت تتزوج وأنت لا تتزوج
وأنت راح تدفع أكثر، لأن عندك سكري
وأنت راح تدفع أقل، لأن أنت أكثر صحةً
وهذه الضريبة راح تدفعها عقابًا
لأن أنت تشرب مشروبات غازية بصورة محددة
مين هذا؟
ضيف
تعرفه؟
لا
حبيت الجراءة هذه
لما كنت تقول دكتور، تبغى تحمي المجتمع من تدخل الآلة الطبية
والآلة الطبية من تدخل المجتمع
طيب أنتوا قاعدين تتدخلون الآن في الثنين
من يحمي المجتمع منكم؟ أو المفترض محد يحمي المجتمع؟
كلام جميل، نحن لا نمتلك استثمار في التغيير
بمعنى الطبيب عنده استثمار في التغيير
الطبيب يبغى يغيّر والمجتمع عنده قابلية أن يغيّر
ويبغى أيضًا الطبيب يتغيّر
وبالتالي، هذا عنده استثمار في أن هذا يتغيّر
وهذا عنده استثمار في أن هذا يتغيّر
بس احنا مثل الحكم في مباراة الملاكمة
هذا يوجّه لكمة لهذا، وهذا يوجّه لكمة لهذا
الحكم ماهو لابس قفازات
ماهو مستثمر في الموضوع العضلي
فقد يتأكد أن العملية عادلة
ويوقف هذه المباراة متى ما أصبحت خارجة عن المألوف
وأصبحت أكثر خطورة مما ينبغي
فنحن الحكم اللي في الوسط هذا
لما كان عندكم مشروع أن تقوم بعض المستشفيات بختم أخلاقي
شلون بتحددون أن هذا أخلاقي؟
عبارة عن قراءة كيف تُعطى بصورة عامة
حتى خارج الإطار الأخلاقي، لأن الكلمة صعبة
لو نبغى نقول أن هذا المستشفى متماشي مع الأنظمة
راح نشوف أنظمة المستشفى هذه، وبنشوف التطبيق حق المستشفى
لأن الأنظمة قد تكون مكتوبة بأفضل شيء
محررة بصورة احترافية، لكن تطبيقها على الواقع غير صحيح
وبالتالي نبغى نشوف أمثلة في الواقع
نأخذ مثال بعيد شوية، أن احنا عندنا اشتراكات
مع المجلة العلمية الفلانية بصورة سنوية
نبغى نشوف كيف تم اختيار المجلة
كيف يتم الدفع، إثباتات أنه تم الاشتراك في المجلة
وإثباتات أنه تم الاستفادة من المجلة هذه
عملية التأكد من واقعية السياسيات هذه في الأرض
متى ما تأكدنا أنه عندهم سياسة
وعندهم أمثلة على تطبيق السياسة هذه
نقدر نقول أنهم متماثلين لما يجب أن يكون
بس دخلنا في مطب أخلاقي
أن كلمة أخلاقي في حد ذاتها تؤدي إلى أن الآخرين غير أخلاقيين
بس ممكن لو كانت اللائحة أو الفكرة هذه فعلًا أخلاقية
فعادي أن هذاك يصير غير أخلاقي
مو «unethical» مقبولة، غير أخلاقي أبدًا غير عادلة
بس هو غير أخلاقي، لأنه ما يتماشي مع الأخلاق
إذا الأخلاق مفترض حتى تخليكم أن لازم أكتب أشياء فعلًا منطقية
أنها تجعل منك أخلاقي أو أنك غير أخلاقي
علشان تقول أن فلان غير أخلاقي وتصمه...
ما أدري أيش معنى أخلاق المصطلح
كلمة «ethical» أو « non-ethical» ما فيها وصم
هي عبارة عن إجراء أن أنا اتخذت قرار بناءً على كذا
أو القرار هذا كان «unethical»
عطني فكرة وتشوف...
عطني سلوك غير أخلاقي
طيب،نأخذ مرة شيء بسيط، اللي هو الموافقة المستنيرة
أن المريض هذا أعالجه مثلًا العلاج هذا
وكان في تقديري أن هو يثق فيني
وأنا قدمت له الوسع، بدلت الوسع فعليًّا في أني ما أخذله
وبالتالي الموافقة المسبقة تحصيل الحاصل
هذا قرار «unethical»
بس لما أجي أبغى أقول غير أخلاقي؛ أنا قاعد أوصم هنا
«unethical» ما فيها وصم، بس غير أخلاقي فيها وصم
المشكلة أني أصم شخص بما يستحق الوصم
أنا باخذ قرارات أخلاقية كثير
بأخذ قرارات متعلقة باستيعاب الناس للفعل هذا
من مجرد خلاف تقني، إلى خلاف في القيمة الأساس
في لب الشخص، أن ترى هذا شخص قذر
كأني أقول أنت قذر الذي لم تفعل كذا وكذا
أنت غير أخلاقي البعيد
غير لما نقول له «unethical» ماهو قذر ترى الـ«unethical»
قد يكون أخذ قرار بناءً على معطيات محددة
ليه ما عندهم ذي الوصمة؟
أحس أنها موجودة
لأن المصطلح نفسه، احنا أسرى للمصطلحات اللي نستخدمها
المصطلح نفسه واصم
لما تقول هذا شريف وهذا غير شريف
المصطلح نفسه واصم، المصطلح يدخل فيه...
يتخذ موقف على طول المصطلح
يصير فيه استقطاب
خصوصًا إذا المصطلح له قيمة وبُعد
نعم، خاصة إذا شيء له علاقة بتحديد الأشياء اللي تؤدي إلى العار
عيب، عار؟
الشيء اللي يدخل في العار
لو قلت لواحد أنت غير أخلاقي كأنك بتزفه زفًا
إلى حفلة أن أنت عار على المجتمع، على التخصص حقك
بينما لو سحبت منها عملية الوصم قد تكون أقل
بس ممكن يكون ما لها قيمة وقتها؟
كيف ما لها قيمة؟
إذا ما لها وقع على الإنسان، أيش الفائدة منها أصلًا؟
إذا أنا مثلًا بفرض باخذها على دولة
نقول دولة أخلاقية أو دولة غير أخلاقية
تخلّي اللأخلاقية أو الأخلاقية
موصومة
الموصومة ما تستطيع تعدل الجينات مثلًا
بس خليت أنه عادي، يمديك تسويه أو يمديك ما تسويه
فمعناته ما في أخلاق، فهمت علي؟
صار هو عادي كأنك وقعت ورقة وللا ما وقعت ورقة
أنا سويت فعلًا أفضل شيء أقدر أسويه، بس عادي
لا، مو عادي
تحس أن الثقة هذه لها قيمة
أنت تحب تلعب في الأطراف البعيدة
وفيه منطقة في الوسط
لا، بس أنك إذا رحت أنت للطرف الأخير تقدر تقيسه
الفكرة أن لا، مو عادي
أنت أخطأت بعدم اتباع ما تعارف عليه الناس أن هذا هو كويس
أنت أخطأت، بس ما سويت حاجة مخجلة، لا يستدعي ذلك الخزي
على سبيل المثال، قطعت إشارة؛ أخطأت
وعرّضت حياة ناس بالغلط، وأستاهل ضرب ليل نهار
وأدفع 3000 مثل برّاد أبو قرشين
لكن أنك تجي تقول لي لقد فعلت فعلًا مخزيًّا خارم للمروءة
وما راح يزوجوك بكرة لا أنت ولا سلسال أهلك للجيل العاشر
عشان قطعت إشارة؛ أقول لك لا
بس خلني أفكر في شيء
أظن أن ما فيه مصطلح تقدر تطلع فيه عند العرب
صح هذه
أعتقد، لأن مرة ملصقة فيهم الأخلاق
بس إذا أنت حرامي؛ أنت لا أخلاقي، صح؟
طبعًا
إيه، فعادي عشان كذا أقول أنك أنت لا أخلاقي لأنك حرامي
بس مو لأنك قطعت الإشارة، رغم أن كلهم جريمتين مثلًا
عشان كذا أنا أبغى أعطي هذا البُعد الآخر
أن اللي قاعد تسويه، ولذا الأخلاق لها قيمة هنا
فيه جريمة واصمة وجريمة لا تعتبر واصمة
قطع الإشارة جريمة
طبعًا ما تعتبر جريمة، إذا نبغى نكون دقيقين قانونيًّا
هي عبارة عن مخالفة
فأنت خالفت الآن بارتكابك قطع الإشارة
لكن هل ارتكبت فعل واصم؟
هل يستطيع الناس يقولوا أن عبدالله خرج من المروءة
لا نقبل له قولًا ولا عدلًا، ولا تُقبل شهادته ولا يُزوج
ولا يُستضاف في المجالس ولا نجيبه في فنجان
علشان قطع إشارة؟
لا، بس أنا أحسها حلوة
هذا المكان الأخلاقي ممكن يكون حتى لأشياء قانونيًّا ماهي مجرّمة
ولا فيها مخالفة ولا فيها أي شيء
لكن لأن أنت تبغى تضبط المجتمع
مثلًا في نطاق العمل وللا في نطاق مثلًا الطب
وللا في الهندسة، وللا في أي مكان، أنك تبغى تضبطه
أنا ما أبي أقول لك مجرّم، لأن هذا القانون بيتخذ
فما يحتاج أصلًا أتكلم معك فيه
سوّها وشوف أيش يصير لك
بس أنا أبغى أضبطها، أني أبغى المجتمع يشوفك عار على المهنة
ليش؟
لأني ما أبغاك تسويها، وللا ما لها قيمة تصير
اضبطها قانونيًّا
ليه؟ بس أن هي فيه شعرة أن ماهو بغلط...
مثلًا، نفرض واحد كذاب
ما يمديك تقفطه، أنت حيوان لأنك تكذب
بس أحيانًا لما تكذّب ما أقدر أسجنك لأن أنت كذاب
إلا إذا كذبت في شهادة أو في شيء معين
بس أن إذا بطبعك؛ بكيفك
بس مفترض أني أطلّعك برّا المجتمع
أنت كذا، أنت إنسان مو كويس
هذا الكلام يمارس الفوقية الأخلاقية، وإطلاق الأحكام
قبول الأشخاص، وطردهم من المجتمع بناءً على رؤيتك
لما هو صح وما هو خطأ
حتى شرعًا الكذب ما يجوز
إيه، بس ما في سلطوية تقول الكذاب اطردوه من المسجد
ما أقول بس
«وما يزال الرجل يكذب ويتحرى الكذب حتى يُكتب عند الله كذَّابًا»
أحس أن فيها وصمة ترى الكذب
لا إله إلا الله، شوف لازم تفرّق ما بين الأداة البشرية والأداة الإلهية
الأخلاقيات الإسلامية بتعتمد على ضبط الإنسان وربه
الأخلاقيات الغربية والأدوات لدراسة الأخلاقيات الغربية
بتعتمد على ضبط العلاقة ما بين الإنسان والإنسان
وهذا ينبني على أشياء كثيرة
ما أقدر أدخل في نيتك، ما أقدر أدخل في أشياء كثيرة
وبالتالي لي الظاهر ويجب حتى لما آخذ بالظاهر
أقول للناس أنا عرّفت الظاهر بناءً على كذا وكذا وكذا
ففيه أدوات محددة تسمح لي أن أدخل في عملية الفوقية هذه
أو أن أنا حكمت على فلان أنه كاذب
بناءً على أنه صار كذا وكذا، وهذا الموقف كانت كذبة شينة
ليش؟ لأن نفسي أنا لما زوجتي تسألني أيش رأيك فيني؟
بقول هو أحسن مخلوق خلقه الله على وجه الكرة الأرضية
كذبة، وكذبةٌ صلعاء أحيانًا، لكنها محمودة
فمن الذي يعطي هذه الفوقية في قبول الكذبة ورفضها؟
كأنك بتقول أنا السلطوي اللي يقبل هذا ويرفض هذا
المجتمع ممكن يعترض
المجتمع كلمة كبيرة، مين؟
لا صدق، اللي هو العامة، أن فيه هذا
مثل لما الحين تسويه، أحس أن المجتمع عندنا مثلًا
فيه أشياء يرضاها وفيه أشياء ما يرضىها، صح؟
بس مين اللي يرضى ومين؟
أنا وأنت ترى المجتمع
تمام، بس احنا كلنا المجتمع؛ أحس أننا نتفق
لا، شلون؟ نصبح الصباح متفقين؟
أحس أن فيه عُرف عند المجتمعات
كيف يجي العُرف هذا؟
بس فيه عُرف وللا ما فيه؟ أنت تتوقع فيه عُرف؟
فيه عُرف، بس مين اللي يقول هذا عُرف وهذا مو عُرف
وجهة النظر اللي أنا بحاول أرد عليها
أن أستاذنا الحبيب بيقول أن أنا اللي راح أقول هذا صح و هذا غلط
ووجهة النظر اللي بحاول أسوّق لها
أن من المستحيل أنا أضبط العلاقة بيني وبين الناس
أنا لازم آخذ أبجديات محددة
هي اللي تحدد كيف أنا أضبط العلاقة
لازم العلاقة هذه تكون منضبطة بناموس محدد الكل يعرفه
لكن ما أتوقع أن نصبح بكرة كمجتمع كلنا كارهين شرب القهوة مثلًا
كمجتمع قررنا، ما تجي، ما يجتمعوا
لازم فيه حملة عشان القهوة
ترى فيها مشاكل ومنبهات، وفيه لها تأثير على مش عارف إيه
وتبدأ الحملة هذه عشان تغيّر الفكر الاجتماعي
يبغى لك عشر سنوات تعمل عليه
وأحيانًا حتى تفشل في تغيير الفكر في النهاية
على سبيل القات مثلًا، كان طبيعي القات
ثم أصبح خاصة في بعض الدول اللي تعتبره عادي
أو الدول المجاورة للدول اللي تعتبره عادي من المواقع الحدودية
أصبح فيه زخم لتغيير العادة الشعبية لاستخدام القات
بسبب أنه يعتبر من المواد المشرعنة أو المواد المنضبطة
التي يجب أن تدخل في نوع من أنواع الضبط
بعد عشرات السنوات من محاولة تسويق فكرة أن لا تاخذوا قات
أصبح القات يتم تداوله بصورة سرية
مثله مثل إذا حاولت تجرّم النيكوتين، إذا حاولت تجرّم الدخان
إذا حاولت تجرّم الشيشة، إذا حاولت تجرّم القهوة
إذا حاولت تجرّم الشاي
فيه أشياء حتى لو حاولت تغير العُرف
راح يتم تداولها بصورة سرية
وأيش يترتب على (Unethical) بالضبط؟
الممارسة غير الأخلاقية
هنا عندنا أنا بوصمك، بس هناك أيش ممكن يصير؟
هناك يصير تأثير على نفس الشخص من ناحية أن...
على حسب طبعًا الخرق أو المخالفة اللي سوّاها
إذا كانت مخالفة بسيطة يُعطى مثلًا أمور تأدبية بسيطة
أنت محتاج أن تدرس مثلًا في التنوّع في
هذه قد تكون شاهد
أحد الزملاء كان من أصل عربي وفي عيادة بريطانية
طبعًا احنا العرب عاطفين بطبعنا
إذا جاء طفل تلاعب الطفل، أحيانًا تلمس الطفل، تقبّل الطفل
نوع من أنواع التودد، ما عندنا مشكلة في ذلك
بالنسبة لهم يعتبروه خرق أخلاقي عظيم
في العلاقة تعاقدية بينك وبين المريض
إذا تعديت حتى ما تسأل الطفل بصورة مباشرة، تستأذن من أبوه
الطبيب هذا، وهذه واقعة فعليًّا
جات بنت أمورة كذا، جاية تتسند على أمها
وجات قربت تلعب جنب الطبيب
وهو بيسولف بيتكلم مع الأم على هذا
وجات مسكت يده ويلعب معاها، ورفع يده وباسها، وكمّل
وطلعت من هناك، ورفعت عليه قضية تحرش، اختلاف ثقافات
فهذا ما يعتبر أنه قصد التحرش
وبالتالي هو فعل فعل غير أخلاقي
ما سوّى شيء غير أخلاقي بتعريف الموضوع الأخلاقي الواصم
لم يقم بما يدعو للوصم، لكنه خالف ماi, متعارف عليه أن لا يخالف
إجراء غير أخلاقي وبالتالي هذا شيء بسيط
راح يُعطى تأديب يتناسب معه
لكن لو قصد مثلًا أن يتودد للطفلة بصورة غير مناسبة
هنا يدخل في الموضوع الغير أخلاقي بتعريفه الواصم
فهي أيش سوّى وأيش العقوبة المناسبة اللي تُسقط على الفعل
بس هذا صار فعل قانوني
في حال منطق القانون مو من منطق الأخلاق
وممكن حتى ماهو أخلاقي عندنا، هو غير أخلاقي عندهم
يمكن أنت غير أخلاقي أنك تبوس طفلة مثلًا في بريطانيا
بس أنه عندنا أخلاقي
هو غير أخلاقي، بس عشان أقول أخلاقي...
لأن هناك ترى مو على المهنة
غلط أنك تسويه على أية حال، صح؟
صحيح بس ما يعتبر تحرش إلا بضبط النية
وبالتالي هم لا يقولون أن كل عملية تودد تحرش
لكن نحن سوف نرفض جميع التوددات عشان نقفل...
سد الدرائع
ما نبغى نفرّق، ما نبغى ندخل في النوايا
فهذا دخّلك في موضوع أنك لا تستطيع أن تصم
ما يتم نشرها في الجرائد، ترى فلان...
عندهم طبعًا الشفافية أن الشخص المتحرش بالأطفال
يتم النشر أن في المنطقة الفلانية فيه متحرّش
فما يتم نشرها إذا واحد مثلًا ثبت أن ما عنده نية تحرّش واضحة
وإن كان فعله يقع ضمن الأفعال اللي غير محبّبة
أو تعتبر تعدّي على ما قالوا بأن هذا ما يجب أن تفعله
قبل أن تتواصل مع الطفلة
ممتاز، فيه سؤال هناك
أهلًا وسهلًا
راح السؤال؟
راح السؤال، أنا عندي سؤال
على سالفة اللي «ساهر»
هو فيه القانون أنك لو تقطع «ساهر» كذا
لكن كل الناس يحسونه عادي
اللي كان يقوله «محمد آل جابر»
أن لازم نخلي قطع «ساهر» أو مخالفة «ساهر»
حاجة عيب وغير أخلاقية، عشان الناس تبدأ تحس بقيمة الفلوس لها
عشان نزيد السلامة؟
إيه
عشان نرفع السلامة؛ ليس بالضرورة أنك تاخذها بالقانون أو بالفلوس
لأنه بيقول خلاص ما في مشكلة
أنت تشوف إن السرعة 300 ريال؟ بدفع 300 ريال
أنا بخالف لأني أقدر أدفع مثلًا
بس مو لأنه عيب
الظاهر أن فيه تجارب على اللي يتأخرون
ولي الأمر مثلًا لما يأخذ طفله من المدرسة، يتأخر عليه
اللي يتأخر قالوا بنعطيك الظاهر 500 ريال غرامة
إذا تأخرت أن تأخذ طفلك
فصار الناس يزيدون، فزاد عدد أولياء الأمور اللي يتأخرون على أطفالهم
بفلوسي
لأن ما أشوف أنه عيب أني خليت ولدي تحت الشمس
لا، خلاص. هي المخالفة كذا؛ يلا ادفع
فالفلوس ماهي معيار
وأنما لما تعطيها وصمة العار، أنك أب عار لطفلك
بس هذه الفكرة مو لازم يشهّر
بجي قبل يدق الجرس حتى
تبغي أرد عليكِ وللا مقتنعة؟
أعتذر طبعًا أني معطيك ظهري
لا محشومة، لا بس لأن المدير قال كذا
خلق عُرف وبالتالي الموصوم هنا
بعض حسني النية سواءً طبيب، سواءً في المرور
حتى الطبيب دخل في موضوع الحوادث والمرور
بس بعض الأشخاص اللي عندهم نوايا حسنة
يعتقدون أن إذا تلاعب في ثوابت المجتمع فهو يخدم المجتمع
بمعنى عملية أن يصبح اللي قطع الإشارة
اللي يصيده «ساهر» موصوم
ما معنى أن تصم شخص؟
هو سوّى خطأ، بس من أنت علشان تصم شخص؟
وهل أنت معصوم من هذه الوصمة؟
إذا قلت أن كل من قطع إشارة سوف أصمه وصمة أخلاقية مؤلمة
بحيث أني أردعه؛ أنت كذا بتتدخل، بتلعب دور إلهي ليس لك
وما ينبغي لك أن يكون، وما كان لك أن يكون ذلك في يوم من الأيام
بكل بساطة لأن الخطأ خطأ والصح صح
الفضيحة فضيحة واللي ماهو فضيحة ماهو فضيحة
أنا لما قطعت الإشارة ما سويت فضيحة، فأنت رجاءً
بس أنت قد تعرّض حياة الناس، أنت قد تقتل عوائل
نعم، صحيح
هذه أكبر فضيحة، لا بالعكس هذا خطأ جريمة
يجب أن يتعامل معي القانون فيها حسب أبجدياتها
لكن لا يصمني بأني غير كفو
أيش اللي يجي، بقول لك الحين لأن أحس يمكن تغيّر رأيك
فيه مقطع أن في الستينيات أو السبعينيات في أمريكا
المقطع هذا جزء من المسلسل
بس أن فيه ناس كانوا طالعين في نزهة وجالسين كذا بحديقة
بعد ما خلصوا؛ نفض الفرشة وأخذها ومشي
والأرض مليانة، قاذوراتهم موجودة، وكان عادي
اليوم أنت تستهجن، ما تقدر تتخيل أنهم كانوا الأمريكان كذا
وكيف تغير؟ هو تغير بأنه أصبح عيب
شوف هذا قذر، هذا يرمي ويمشي؛ فامتنعوا
ما صارت بالمخالفة، لأن لو بالمخالفة؛ ما في مشكلة
عطني 100 ريال ويلا روح ونظّف أنت وراي، فهمت الفكرة؟
فهمت عليك
ما هي إلهية، بالعكس أحس أنها تربي المجتمع
طيب حجة مضادة
ما رأيك في النهب؟
غلط
مو بس غلط، واصم
الشخص اللي يمتهن النهب؛ هذا شخص لا يُقبل منه صرفًا ولا عدلًا
ولا يجي فنجان حتى، أبدًا الشخص اللي ينهب هذا غير مقبول
الشواهد، دائمًا بستخدمها حتى في المحاضرات
في عام 2011 أو 2012، التاريخ يخونني قليلًا
صار في لندن بالتحديد، اللي هو الجمعة السوداء
بما أن احنا قريبين من الجمعة السوداء
الجمعة السوداء موسم تخفيضات عظمى
التلفزيون أبو 200 باوند يصير بعشرة باوند
شيء غير طبيعي في هذيك الفترة كانت
اللي صار أن الناس من الساعة 12:00 ينتظرون أمام المحلات الكبرى
عشان يحصل على الأجهزة قبل أن تنفذ
تلفزيون، اللي يبغى جوال، أو أيًّ كان
فجأت الساعة 12:00، «بيق بن» على الساعة 12:00
قبل أن تنفتح البوابات؛ تزاحم الناس في الدخول
وأصبح فيه فوضى عارمة وتضارب شديد
في عملية اختطاف الأجهزة
ثم تطور الموضوع إلى عملية تخريب
تطور الموضوع إلى أن من مستحيل السيطرة على الجموع هذه
صار كلٍ ياخذ ويطلع من المحل
خرج جزء كبير من الناس، عجبهم الفوضى هذه اللحظية
فصارت فوضى عارمة
أصبح نوع من أنواع الثورة في شوارع لندن
استمرت يمكن يومين أو ثلاثة أيام، حرائق، اعتداءات
خرج الموضوع عن السيطرة خروج كامل
هذا هو المجتمع اللي احنا بنقول ان هذا مجتمع مثالي وكويس
وبينظّف وراه ومش عارف أيش
أيش اللي حصل بعد الساعة 12:00 في الجمعة السوداء؟
بكل بساطة دفع الجموع ومضنة الخروج من العقاب
سواءً المدفوعات في الحقيقة
أو أني أُسجن عل هذا، لأن بتذوب في مليون فعل خطأ
وقد يكون سرقة التلفزيون أقلها خطأً
ما بين السرقات والقتل والحرق والاغتصابات
يجي واحد معاه تلفزيون؛ توكل على الله
يدفّعوه غرامة وخلوه يمشي
هذه مجرد حجة مضادة لموضوع أن الآداب راسخة بالوصم عند الغربيين
عند البشر
أنت استخدمت المصطلح الغربي
إيه، الغربي كمثال
بس يمكن لو جيت تسوي عيب
حتى يمكن الآن، لما يصير عيب؛ الناس تبدأ تقلل
لما تشوف واحد يرمي ورقة؛ كذا بتعطيه نظرة
أحس هذه النظرة عن ألف ريال
صح، شوف أنا لا أجادل في فاعليتها
هي فاعلة، لكن هل هي عادلة؟
أتوقع اختلافنا أن أنا أقول إيه وأنت تقول لا
أنا أقول أن ماهي عادلة، لأن الشخص اللي يحدد
بناءً على أسباب اقتصادية
أنا على سبيل المثال، جالس في مكان
وحصل أن سبت الفضلات حقتي ومشيت؛ خطأ
ما في أحد عاقل يقول أن هذا التصرف سليم
لكن أنا بدفع ضرائب مثلًا، فيه جهة بتدفع ضرائب
وفيه أشخاص بيجوا بعد ما أنا أطلع، ومدفوع لهم ضرائب
مدفوع لهم راتب من الضرائب اللي أنا قاعد أدفعها؛ عشان ينظفوا
وهذا في المجتمعات اللي مبنية الخدمات على الضرائب
ما بتكلم عن مجتمعنا
قد يكون هذا سبب يخلي الناس يتخذوا هذا الفعل
اللي أبغى أقوله هنا، أن الفعل في حد ذاته
ماهو مجرد ذو قيمة أخلاقية
فأنت إذا تبغى تتدخل وتعطيه قيمة أخلاقية
أنت بتمارس دور ماهو دورك
مهما كانت شناعة الفعل هذا
إذا تبغى تتدخل وتعطي قيمة أخلاقية لأسباب أخرى
أسباب اقتصادية، ما تتزوجوا أنتوا علشان ما تجيبوا لي
طفل يكلفني مليون في السنة
هذا ترى سبب اقتصادي
بس بحاول أعطي له قيمة أخلاقية
علشان أنا استفيد اقتصاديًّا
وفي الطريق أنت بتستفيد أن ما بيكون عندك مشكلة
وعندك أسرة صحية
مثلًا قبل ما تتزوج لازم تثبت لأبو العروسة أن أنت ما عليك ديون
جِيب كشف حساب حقك
وتجيب «سمة» كمان
إيه نعم، و«سمة» أن أنت ما قد تلاعبت
في أي نوع من أنواع الأقساط عندك
فهذا نوع من أنواع التدخلات اللي لها فائدة اقتصادية محددة
لكنها تصل إلى مرحلة الوصم
لفعل لا يحمل القيمة الأخلاقية، فهذه هي المشكلة
من هو الذي لديه القدرة على أن يصم فعلًا عاديًّا لسبب ما؟
مهما كان السبب هذا
هنا أنت بتلعب في عدادات القيم، وتخليها قيم مادية
أكثر من القيم اللي نحن جميعًا متعارفين عليها
وورثناها أن هذه قيم
بس أحس أنه نقاش طويل
لأن اللي تعارفنا عليه هو ناس قرروا أن هذه قيم
جالسة تطور وتتغير، خالية من المرؤة، كانت شيء
وجالسة تتطور وتتغير
صحيح
فهو كذا هو شيء يُخلق في الجو العام
ماهو عبدالله وللا أيمن وللا عبدالرحمن اللي يقررونه
أو واحد منهم يقرر، وهم كلهم كذا فجأة يقولون ما عندهم هذه الحركات
ليتها كذا، اللي بيحصل...
ترى هذه الفكرة
مو بفجأة، بس شوي شوي
لأن مثلًا يمكن 2005 لو تطلع في الرياض
لو تبغى تروح البقالة، إذا منت لابس شماغك وعقال
تصير كذا، ليش طالع ببدلة؟ وللا ليش طالع مفرّع؟ وللا حاسر الرأس؟
ليش؟ والحين صار عادي. هي كذا شوي شوي
أو اللي كان يأكل في الأماكن العامة كان هذا خارم للمروءة
والحين صار عادي
نادر اللي يأكل في بيته
أنا معك في تطور المجتمع، لكن القيم قيم
تبقى خوارم المروءة خوارم المروءة
تغيّرت، مثلًا لأن أول كان معنى أن تطلع حاسر الرأس
أن أنت من سفهاء المجتمع
الشخص الراكز يلتزم باللبس المقبول
إلى الآن لو شخص طلع بلبس مخل مثلًا، تعال وين أنت؟!
إلى هذه اللحظة
فزمان كان تعريف اللبس المخل هو أنك تخرج حاسر الرأس
القيمة ما تتطور كقيمة، لا تزال القيمة
لأن فيه كود لازم تلتزم فيه
لكن تعريف هذا القيمة والتطبيق حقها اختلف
وهذا اللي قابل للتطور، لكن القيمة قيمة لا تمس ثابتة
لا يجي واحد مثلًا بلباس البحر يراجع الدوائر الحكومية
غير مقبول
راح يشوف أيش يصير له
حديث لا يحس بالوقت معكم
والله أكرمتنا بوقتك